hello everyone here on freeco Camp my
name is Anya Kubo and I'm a software
developer as well as a course creator
here on freecodecamp as well as on my
own channel in this video I'll be
showing you three ways to build one
thing
I'm going to show you how to build a
buzzfeed clone in JavaScript followed by
a version in reacts using Jason Saba for
mimicking an API and then build a
typescript buzzfeed clone with a mini
backend using node.js to communicate
with our external database
so a lot of Technologies and the coolest
part about this app is I will also
prompt you to the next question once you
answer the ones above and scroll to the
top most unanswered question use some
cool scroll logic that we will write
together okay so what are we waiting for
let's find out what cheese we are thanks
to building out BuzzFeed in these three
different ways ranging in difficulty and
Technology
okay so here we are on my code editor of
choice I'm using webstorm which means
all I have to do is start a new project
and I'm going to create an empty project
and just go ahead and call this Buzz
feeds
clone JS okay so all I'm going to do is
Click create and that will spin up a new
directory for me of course you are free
to use whatever code editor you wish so
if you're using vs code or anything like
that just go ahead and create a
directory and open it up in vs code
once you have done that we're just going
to add in some new files so we're going
to create an index HTML file making sure
to give it the HTML extension and then
also create a style sheet my style so
Styles CSS
and then also a Javascript file which
I'm going to call app.js just like so
so there we go those ro3 files make sure
to put in those extensions so that your
code editor knows to treat them as a
HTML file CSS file and JavaScript file
now first off well we're going to be
doing the majority of this in JavaScript
okay because we want to populate the
question based off some data but we can
put a little bit of stuff in here so
let's go ahead and just change the title
of this document that so that it shows
up in the browser when we open this up
so I'm going to put BuzzFeed clone and
then of course we need to link up the
style sheet so we do this using the link
tag Rel
sheets and then we also have to put the
href which will take us to our style CSS
file as it's in the root of the project
we could just put the file name like so
and of course we need the script tag
making sure that it's at the end so
after everything in here loads then we
read the JavaScript at the moment there
isn't anything in here but just make
sure that that's at the bottom anyway
and we're going to link it to the app.js
file
now in here I'm actually just going to
create a section and in this section we
are going to have a header that says
what cheese are you now we could have
fed this in from the data but you know
I'm going to show you how to feed in
data anyway so if you choose to find the
title after this then that is your
choice and then we're also just gonna
have a fun little paragraph underneath
it this quiz isn't cheesy
or anything
okay so making sure to spell anything
correctly so so far that's what's in our
section I'm also going to get a div and
we are going to be injecting stuff into
this div using JavaScript what we're
going to be injecting is the questions
so I'm going to pick this out I'm going
to give this ID of questions and then
I'm also going to create a div where I'm
going to inject the answer once we've
answered all the questions so I'm going
to give this the ID of answer so you
could also pick it out in our JavaScript
so this is it this is really everything
we have in here does it fit yeah there
you go it all fits kind of nicely I can
even make it smaller if you want so that
you can literally everything
okay and then this would be the proper
indentation as well so script section
cool
nice
so that is our HTML done uh what should
we do first should we give this some
basic styling yeah let's do it I'm
actually going to put my style sheet
over here
and I'm just going to open up this index
HTML file in the browser so with
webstorm I could just go ahead and click
this
and I will open up the document in our
browser I'm just going to inspect this
so you can see what's going on so there
you'll see the body with the section
with H1 tag the paragraph and the two
divs that I made or if you're using uh
other code editors you can also do this
by going into the project clicking on
the index.html file right clicking and
then just copying the path the absolute
path and go back to the browser and
pasting it like so okay it's it's the
same thing
so there we go which cheese are you
let's give this a little bit of styling
so the first thing I'm going to do is
actually just make sure that everything
is centered so I'm going to grab the
body let's make this a little bit bigger
and again I'm just going to minimize
this
and move this over perhaps
so I've grabbed the body and I'm going
to use display
flexed initialize Flex box and I'm just
going to justify content Center to make
everything centered horizontally and
then all I'm going to do is grab the
section and the section I'm going to
hard code the width to be 600 pixels
okay
so that is how coded it won't change
I'm also going to grab the H1 element
and just give it the font size
what font size we want to give this we
can work in Ram 2.5 RAM and then let's
give it a line
height of
0.1.05 text align left so we don't want
it to be centered and also the P element
uh well with this let's also give it a
font size we can do it in Ram
so like that and also give it a line
height
of 1.2
great so now if we look in a browser
and just hit refresh
there we go so this section is kind of
in the center and has a hard-coded width
of 600 and the text is aligned left and
the fonts have been changed now if I
want to actually use a different font
see I'm like no I'm not keen on this one
and it doesn't look like what BuzzFeed
does we can actually pick out a font
thanks to Google fonts so I'm going to
do that too we're going to have to
import it so there is a font that I
found that I quite like
it's Montserrat and it's the closest
thing to the one on BuzzFeed so let's go
to Google fonts
let's search for monsterat
and I'm just going to select let's
select a few so I can do the thin one
the light one
medium we can really just pick out all
of these if we want and if we view them
I can use the import we could do in the
HTML or we could do it directly in the
CSS file so I'm going to do it in the
CSS file so I'm going to copy all of
this and then
just at the top here I'm just going to
paste that in okay so I'm actually going
to minimize this so you can see
everything I've just pasted in that
entire line which will give me the font
Montserrat along with the weights okay
so that's what it looks like and now I'm
going to apply this font to everything
all the elements in my document so star
means everything
and I'm just going to do font
family
month
so rat making sure to spell it the same
and sounds
serif
cool
so that is looking good so now if I go
to my clone and refresh that font has
now been applied
wonderful
let's
carry on
so now I think it's time for us to start
injecting the questions into here
so
let's get up our appsius file and the
first thing that I'm going to do is just
pick out these so I'm going to pick out
this div by the ID questions so I'm
going to use documents it's a little bit
bigger
query selector and look for the ID of
questions
and I'm going to save this as
a question
display
the next thing I'm going to do is the
same for the answer display so cons
answer display and I'm going to look in
my document my HTML document and then
look for something with the ID of
answer and I believe it was a singular
answer answer that's right so we've
picked those two things out and now
let's get to injecting stuff into them
and what I want to inject is stuff from
this data so const questions is it going
to be an array of all the data that
we're going to use for this quiz
so
we need sir three questions we're going
to answer three questions in order to
find out what cheese we are so each
question is going to be essentially an
object so there's one
there's another
there's another and now I'm going to
give each question an ID so we can keep
track of it so this is going to have ID
0. each one is also going to have the
actual text of the question question so
let's go ahead and put pick a vacation
destination
and then we're also going to have
the answers available to us so there's
going to be an array because there's
going to be four of these and each one
is going to have essentially one of our
choices so the first choice is going to
be New York
uh we're gonna have an image for it
so we're going to put the image in here
which is going to be essentially a URL
to unsplash.com is where you can get
loads of free images but you do need to
credit them we also need to add some
alternative text so I'm going to put a
photo of the
Empire State
building during daytime
again I'm just going to get rid of that
and then we have to give this credit
right because unsplash asks you to do
that so we're going to put the credit of
this photo which is
Oliver
nubat
okay and I actually have the URL already
so I'm just going to go ahead
and paste it in here like so if you want
to get this specific URL then please
visit uh my description where I'm going
to share this code so you can take this
or you can find your own image okay just
visit
images.unsplash.com and find a cool
image of New York and just grab the
whole URL to do it so for those of you
who perhaps haven't done this before you
can get any image really so for example
if I visit Wikipedia
and just type in
New York and if I want to get a picture
of New York City I can literally just
essentially what I'm doing is left
clicking on here copying the image
address
and then this is essentially the images
so that's exactly what I'm doing apart
from minor not from Wikipedia they're
from unsplashed
so
that's what we need in order to get one
answer so now let's do another so this
is the form that it needs to take
so let's open up our curly braces
and I'm not going to subject you to this
because you know I've already kind of
done this for you so we're gonna have
New York we're also going to have Austin
with a time lapse photography of cars
and then we're also going to have
Portland with a photo taken by Elena
kuchko
so there we go
and then last one we're gonna have
New Orleans
okay so that's just one question we have
two more to go so making sure that is
finished now so here we go that's our
first question
we're gonna make another so let's give
this the idea of one this time
and let's carry on this time the text is
going to be pick some food and the
answers
are going to be so let's open up our
array let's get the first answer the
first answer is going to be a pizza so
you can choose to select a pizza with a
photo of some pepperoni pizza by Ellen
Hardman let's open up another object the
second one is going to be a sandwich
because who doesn't love sandwiches so
there we go uh the third one is going to
be some pasta it's actually going to be
some pasta and tomato sauce
and then finally the fourth one
is going to be a hamburger so I'm just
going to paste that in like so so there
we go that's our second object and our
third question so id2 is going to have
the text of picker home this time so
this is how the three important
questions apparently for how to find out
what cheese you are and the answers are
going to be well let's get up our first
object
so our first answer is going to be a
traditional home so I'm just going to
paste that in here like so
our second answer is going to be a
modern home this time
so I'm just going to paste that in
and then we're going to have an actual
house
so like a full-on house with a garden
everything
and then the last one is going to be the
mountains like some cabin in the
mountains or something like that
wonderful so that's all our data done
please go ahead and check you know like
obviously that's working with arrays and
objects it can get kind of messy so if
you're getting any issues just check out
my code below
cool so now let's use all this data in
order to create some questions so what
I'm going to do is actually write a
function
um
I'm going to use a function expression
for this so populate questions
that's what I'm going to call it
so just like that and when we call this
well for each question in my questions
array so if here's a questions array and
here's each question we've got three in
here right so four each item in my
questions array which I'm going to
choose a cool question you can call it
whatever you like and call it I if you
wish I like to give it you know some
readable value
so for each of those what I'm going to
do is use document create making sure to
spell document correctly document create
element and I'm just going to create a
div so I'm going to call this div
something I'm going to call it title
block
okay and this title block I'm going to
give it the ID of the question ID okay
so we can just keep track of it that
will be useful later what I'm also going
to do is get the title block class list
and we're going to make a class called
title block so we can see it in our
browsers and before we do anything else
let's just see what this looks like so
of course we made the div we've got an
ID we've given a class name a title
block but we also need to put it in to
our questions display so let's grab the
questions display
and I'm going to use append
to put in the title
lock
wonderful and of course we need to call
this so we can actually make this
function do something it's just been
called otherwise nothing would happen
and now let's style this up a little bit
like a block so we can see something in
the browser
so class of title block because we added
a class and the title block well I'm
just going to hard code each one to have
a width of
600 pixels a height of 210 pixels
a background color what we're going to
do RGB and then 102 96 221
and then we're going to do a border
radius of 5 pixels
display
Flex
justify content because we want to
Center everything in the center and we
also want to align so we've just
centered everything horizontally if we
want to Center everything vertically too
so it's like literally in the middle we
do a line content Center and make sure
that it's got a height otherwise that
will not work and of course these two
will not work without the display Flex
and let's also give the text of
everything in here some uh just white so
I'm gonna do
cool
so that's our title block
so now if I look in the browser I should
see three question blocks right ta-da
one
two
three but they're kind of like scrunched
up on each other
um which is fine for now because we're
going to be adding the question options
in here too or the question answers I
call them
okay but first we also need to add a
heading in here so let's go ahead and
put a heading inside this div we just
created so the div that we called in our
JavaScript title block
so let's go back in here so let's create
another element so we want to put in
let's put an H2 tag so I'm going to use
document create element by putting
document here doesn't mean I'm actually
putting it in the document yet okay it's
kind of floating around in nowhere we
have to put it in using append
so that's something that might trip you
up
let's create an H2 tag and I'm just
going to save this as title heading just
like so and title
hedging
text content equals the question
text so for each question in here so
again this is one question I'm going
into the question because I've chosen to
call it question and I'm getting the
text we've already got the ID now we're
getting the text next we're going to get
the answers which is an array which
which means we're going to have to use
four each again on this array but don't
worry I'll walk you through that when
the time comes
cool so we've given the title heading we
made an H2 tag we've given it the text
from our data and of course next we need
to put it in and we want to put it in
the
title block right so title block append
title
heading
cool so I believe that's it so if we
look in the browser and hit refresh so
here's the divs we made there's nothing
in them at the moment and if we refresh
that ta-da we have put in the H2 element
with the title
wonderful
let's carry on
so perhaps let's also style up our H2
tags because I want them to be a little
bit bigger so I want to override the
default styling for the h
to element and I want the H2 element to
have a font
size of 3.5 Ram
a line height of 1.05 and I want to text
and what the text is already in the
center so we don't need to
do that
cool
so the next thing I want to do is just
create a block for all my questions to
go and so all four of them so once again
I'm going to do document to create
element I'm going to create a div I'm
going to call this const question Z
block
and I'm going to give the question block
the ID as well so question block ID this
time the ID obviously happens to be
different because we can't use the same
ID
um that's literally the not the point of
IDs they're meant to be unique so I'm
just going to add the string of
questions as well so we can pick it out
later and the question block I'm also
give it the class list add of answer
options so perhaps we should call this
answers block
now let's keep it like it is I hope
that's not too confusing so now let's
actually give some styling to this
so answer options uh and the answer
options I just want to make sure that
all four items are going to go in this
are going to be spaced out evenly so I'm
going to use display oops making sure
that that's in here
display Flex
and I'm also going to make it Flex wrap
wrap so I'll show you what this looks
like without it and I'm going to justify
content space between so that there's a
space in between them not around because
I want it to go all the way up to the
edges so space between will literally
give like a little Gap in the middle
between the objects
cool and perhaps Also let's give it a
margin just at the top 16 pixels Zero
from the side 23 pixels at the bottom
and zero to the right
wonderful so we've made a div that will
store all our questions the next thing
I'm going to do is actually populate
the
um
the the on the div with the class of
answer options so I'm going to do so by
getting the question answers
and then four each so this is exactly
what I said earlier we're getting the
question answers and using four each so
we can essentially use these four items
to do stuff
for each answer
I'm going to create an element so
document create element and I'm going to
create a div let's call this answer
block
okay and the answer block
is also going to have a class class list
add of
singular answer block
do you know what let's call this answers
block because it's annoying me I feel
like it should answers
block
answers block
okay yeah because the answers block is
going to hold all our answer blocks that
makes way more sense
okay so our answer block we're adding
the class of answer block so perhaps
let's go ahead and add that too I'm
essentially just going to make them like
uh little squares that have a width of
286 pixels and a height of 286 pixels
let's round them off a little bit so
border radius I'm gonna get five pixels
and I'm also going to give it a box
Shadow so box shadow
RGB a because I want the to be
transparent I'm going to do black so
that's black and then 0.07 opacity okay
and then we want zero
horizontal
zero vertical zero
uh blur but then one
um
spread okay cool one pixel that should
be those can be zero without a unit but
that needs to have pixel
okay and I'm going to make the text
align
Center
I'm going to give it some margin at the
bottom let's just say 15 pixels and
overflow
hidden okay so that if anything comes
out of this box like an image that we
want to put in then it will be cut off
cool so we've done quite a bit I'm not
going to show you the browser because we
haven't actually put this in if I wanted
to though I guess I could put the
answers Block in and we put the answers
block into the question display so we've
already put in the title block
and outside this for loop I can also now
put in the
answers block so now if we look in the
browser you will see r
title block but also
the div that we made with the id0
questions that have the class answer
options and we haven't put anything in
it that's what we're literally doing now
we're going to put the four questions in
at the four answer blocks in it
so let's go back
we've added a class to that answer block
next we're going to get the answer block
and use add event listener to listen out
if we click on the option and for now
I'm just going to put handle click
which of course we haven't written yet
so that's equal back function uh const
handle
click
so we'll write that later I'm just going
to write console.log
clicked for now
great
so next we're going to put in the image
so we're going to use document create
element and create an image element and
I'm going to save this as answer image
and we're going to use so let's get the
answer
image that we just created and I'm going
to use set attribute
to set the source of the image as the
answer
image
okay because We're looping the same this
time We're looping we're already in the
loop this is our second Loop and we're
getting the answer
image we're also going to have to get
the answer text and alternative text and
credit so alt is the next one that I
want to do
so answer
image set attribute this time alt and
I'm just going to get the answer
Alt
Okay so we've done that of course we
haven't put it anywhere else yet we are
going to have to essentially append that
to the answer block itself so down here
still on the loop
I'm going to get the answer block
and I'm gonna append
the answer
image so we've got the image the next
thing we want to do is uh create the
I guess like a little answer title so
let's go ahead and do that document
create
element and I'm going to create an H3
tag this time I'm going to save this as
answer
title
and I get the answer
and I'm going to use text content to
just give it the answer
text it wasn't titled it was answered
text because that's what we're getting
we've got the answer text
okay
so we've done that we've got the answer
title so now let's put it in so we're
going to put it in after the image so
this order does matter because it's
literally the order we're going to be
putting these elements in
until after we have the answer title
we're going to have the answer info so
I'm going to create a document again
create document create element and I'm
just going to create a paragraph element
and I'm going to save this as answer
info
now I'm going to get answer info and use
text content
uh or am I
no I'm not because we're gonna have to
make some links in here as well so let's
create a link I'm going to call it image
link
document
create element a tag and with the image
Link Link a
image
link I'm going to use set
attribute to set the href to be the
answer
credit so that's essentially who created
this image right we also have one more
link to make and that's the source link
which will essentially just give us a
link to unsplash
so document create element another a tag
let's get the source link I'm going to
use text content to assign the well just
the string on
Splash right and then if we click on it
so source
link set attribute I'm going to set the
source to be
https
www dot unsplash
dot com
cool so once we have all of that I'm
going to get answer info and I'm going
to use a pen to put in first off the
image link then just the string two with
some spaces around it and then the
Source link
okay so that's our answer info let's go
ahead and also put it in the answer
block
so just gonna put it in
here
and before we do that we actually need
to get the answers block and append
the whole answer block
itself
cool so now if we look in here and hit
refresh
handle click okay right that's fine
we'll just do that for now
so I made a call back
and we'll just do that for now and ta-da
this is looking great there's a few
things that didn't work however why is
the P tag not showing up
so there's a P tag but it seems to be
kind of below there
seems to be some sort of styling issue
so let's solve it
so we've done overflow hidden
um perhaps we should actually stall the
image itself as well so
I feel like obviously without the
Overflow hidden we would see all the
other stuff but I'm just going to say
that any image that exists in the answer
block well I'm just going to give it a
width of 100 fast
okay so that's looking a little bit
better this is it's just too big that
text that's why it isn't fitting to my
wanted size so I'm gonna once again get
the answer block and say that any P tag
that lives in here is going to have the
font size 11 pixels and the font
Style
italic okay and just the same I'm going
to actually get the answer block
and say that any a tags that live in
here are going to be gray so let's give
it the color RGB
oh let's just do I don't know which
color we should do so I'm just going to
use this to pick out a kind of grayish
color RGB one one okay
RGB
just to keep everything kind of
consistent even though I know we put RAM
for one font size and pixels here I'll
go back and change that later
so now
ta-da
even though why is this not working
to unsplash
this should have a name so let's go back
to our code
image link
hrefr okay the image link also needs
some text so image link
text content equals answer
credit as well
so that should actually show the name as
well as link to it cool so that is
looking wonderful this is looking so
good why is this one not
centered however
hmm let's start the H2 tags just to make
sure that everything is centered was H2
text align
Center
wonderful pick a destination pick some
food and pick a home so now that we've
done that let's get to writing our
function for the handle click to handle
our clicks so what this means is that I
want to actually collect all the
questions that have been answered make
all the others disabled and do some
scrolling as well to make sure that we
scroll to the uppermost unanswered
question
so let's do this let's get up our app.js
file
so okay I'm gonna get rid of this now
in the handle click well what do we want
to happen well if we click on the actual
Square
um we want to know which question it
belongs to is it question one two or
three so we're going to have to pass
that in to the handle click here so
let's open this up
and for whatever question we are on so
question ID that's what we're going to
pass through we're going to pass through
the question ID
and we're also going to pass through the
answer
text
okay so I don't need to call it the same
in here in fact let's definitely not I'm
going to call this
question ID and chosen answer
so now if I console log
what we are passing through
just hit refresh
so click that's the question ID because
we're on question zero which is pick a
destination and I've clicked on New York
Austin and if I click on here this is
question two so we've got the id1 and
ID to Modern traditional and so on
so that's working that is good now let's
use this to our advantage
so
what do I want to happen well actually
what I would quite like is to make an
array of unanswered questions so that we
can essentially work with it so I'm
going to do so perhaps right under the
data so right here I'm going to go const
on answered
questions and make this an empty array
so unanswered questions
why is this not like it on on
I don't even notice for answer anymore
I've said it so many times on answered
oh my gosh
okay I'll answer the questions so I'm
going to get this array and I'm actually
going to push in
um
each question ID
and I can do somewhere We're looping
over each question so let's maybe just
go ahead and I mean we can do whatever
we want so unanswers questions and I'm
going to push the
question ID in here
okay so when we create all the questions
all of the questions are going to go in
the unanswered array okay because
they're unanswered yet but however if we
click on one well first off we
essentially need to get rid of something
from the answered unanswered questions
right but we also need to make another
array of chosen answers so I'm going to
do that up here const chosen answers
again an empty array
I'm going to get the chosen
answers array
and push in the
chosen
answer
now
we probably want to do this
only if the unanswer so
if
unanswered questions includes
the question ID
so say we click on question with ID 0
and we click on something in there it
goes oh yes it's included so it's
unanswered so we can go ahead and push
our chosen answer in here and then we
can also remove that from the unanswered
questions so let's get our unanswered
questions again and I'm going to use
index
of
question ID and then save this as item
to remove
and then if
item to remove is larger than -1
I'm going to get the unanswered
questions and splice
item to remove
so that is how you would remove
something from an array based on its
answer okay so I'm essentially finding
the item to remove and I'm looking and
answer the question and I'm getting rid
of it okay so that's the piece of code
to do that so now
I'm just going to console okay
console.log
the chosen
answers but then also console log
unanswered
questions
so let's look in the browser
so if I pick traditional we pick
traditional that's been put in our
chosen answers array and you will see
that on unanswered questions now consist
of zero and one because question zero
hasn't been answered and question one or
with id1 hasn't answered we have a
question with id2 has been answered so
it's been taken out of the array cool
right and if I go ahead and maybe pick
one from here
okay so just this one to answer now
sandwich so now all our questions are
answered there's nothing in the
unanswered array and those are our three
chosen answers
cool rights but we are not yet done of
course we have like edge cases and stuff
to do
so if
there's basically nothing in our
unanswered
questions array so on answer questions
length
does not exist
well then I just want to
show the answer right because we've
answered all three there's nothing
unanswered questions we want to show the
answer and ideally we want to scroll to
something so I'm going to put scroll to
answer
div
okay so that is something that will
happen we also want to essentially
disable
the question blocks right the ones that
haven't been chosen so disable question
block or the entire question block minus
the one that we chose of course uh and
to do this we're going to pass through
the question ID into here and the chosen
answer as well and then we're also going
to have to
scroll to top most unanswered
question in fact we could do this now so
let's do this before writing the
disabled question block because I'm
going to show you how to do that so to
do this well we need to find the lowest
question ID
and to do this we're going to use a math
Min okay math Min will return the lowest
value from an array so I'm going to get
that array and I'm going to destructure
it to get all my unanswered questions
and pass them through into math men like
so and that will give us the lowest
question ID and I just want to scroll to
it so I can use location H ref to scroll
to the ID of
whatever the lowest question ideas so
let's check it out
um I'm of course going to have to
comment out show answer because we don't
have that yet
so now
let's start at the top I'm going to pick
New York and then it takes me to the
second question and I pick one and it
takes me to the third question same for
if I start on the third question it
should take me to the first question and
it does pick a vacation destination and
Let's do let's start on the second
question so one two and it should take
me to the top one great and if I answer
that
amazing so it's taking us to the top
most unanswered question I hope that was
useful I thought that was pretty cool
let's carry on
so now what shall we do let's show the
answer yeah let's go ahead and do that
so const show answer
and all I'm gonna do is uh essentially
show so we're going to create an answer
block first
I'm just going to move this down a
little bit
so document create element and I'm going
to create a div
and I'm going to save this as answer
block
now I'm going to grab the answer block
and I'm going to use class list add
result
block
I want the result block to be pink so
the answer to be pink so let's go ahead
and do that I'm going to get the result
block and I'm just going to give it a
width
of 600 pixels
a background
color
of RGB
255 61158
any border
radius of 5 pixels
okay so that's what my results block is
gonna look like
um
we'll do some more styling in a bit but
for now I'm just going to add that and
then what else do we want to do well we
want to have a title so let's go ahead
and once again use document create
element to create a H3 tag which I'm
going to save as answer
title
now I'm going to get the answer title
and I'm going to use text content and
it's going to give it the result
text
and then I'm also going to get the
answer image and I'm going to use
document
create element to create an image
and I'm going to get the answer image
and I'm going to use set attribute to
set the source to be well we're actually
going to have to write some data for
this right
so I'm going to go ahead and name this
answers and it's going to be array of
all the possible combinations of answers
that I have so it's not actually going
to be all of them because you know we
need a lot of data for this so I'm just
going to essentially make four and then
make a default answer as well of course
if you actually got all three
combinations that would be a lot more
but hopefully you know that and if you
really want to make all the combinations
then please go right ahead so if the
combination is
New York in any order by the way New
York
is that so it doesn't matter which way
you put this in the array but we will do
that in the code
uh traditional making sure this has to
be spelled exactly the same otherwise it
will not work then the answer that you
get is blue cheese or blue cheese
and then the image that you get is going
to be again from unsplash just a picture
of some blue cheese that I found so
there we go once again that will be in
the code that I provided and we're going
to have to provide some alt text so I'm
just going to go ahead and put Alt
blue cheese
okay so that's one answer that it could
be now I'm just going to copy paste
these
four and then like I said we're gonna
have a default the default one is just
going to be
um
well
it could just be the first one we'll
decide that later so for this one if we
choose
Austin
pasta
modern
you get to be
cheddar so I'm going to change this to
be cheddar cheese
and that is going to be the image and
then this one is going to be Portland
sandwich
mountains
the image we'll put in later and you are
a feta cheese I'm gonna put feta let's
put feta here too and one last one let's
put New Orleans
hamburger
house
and then you get to be halloumi
let's get rid of that
as well and I'm just gonna put
halloumi cheese
wonderful so those are our answers like
I said the combinations
need to have a default
answer
to
compensate for a lack of combination
data okay
so in the show answers
we're going to have to essentially get
the the answer right of the combinations
so I'm going to put this as
results so let result
and we're going to get all the answers
and for each answer
if our chosen answers includes
the first item from the answer
combination
array
and
the second answer and the third answer
so if three of those are included then
the result
is the answer which will be an object
right it will be the whole object of the
answer
else
make sure to spell answer correctly
which is going to default to the first
answer
object is default
so I'm just going to assign the value of
answers
first item to the result
okay so great that will give us our
answer so if I console log
results
let's just check sure okay so that's
being called
so if I go ahead and pick New York
Pizza
traditional
okay so that is our answer we get the
answer which is an object that has the
alt blue cheese the combination the
image of some blue cheese and the text
blue cheese so that is cool now we need
to get the answers essentially text
we need to also get the image and all
that and assign it to
here so the answer image result image is
going to be the answer image
we're also going to get the answer image
and we're going to use set attribute to
set the source and the result
alternative text
and now we're going to get the actual
answer block
to the answer block
and we're going to append
the answer
title and the answer image
cool and then we're actually also going
to get the answers display that we
picked out and append the answer block
which has all three of which has all two
of those things in it so answer
block
cool
so that is looking good let's have a
look to see if that has worked
so once again
one two three
and there we go even though the blue
cheese image is not working why is that
there must be something wrong with our
data
okay so that's fine
oh that should say Alt
so there we go
so now some things we need to do are
actually disable
any other clicking right because
otherwise two Jesus show up and we don't
want that we can't have that so I'm
going to show you how to essentially get
all the um answer blocks and essentially
disable them
so we're going to do this on the show
answer right at the end of the show
answer
function
clean this up a little bit
so let's get all the answer blocks again
const all answer blocks because we have
to get them in their current state or
onto blocks document
query selector
all I'm going to look for anything with
the I class name sorry of answer
block
and once we have that we're going to
create an array from this array
from all answer blocks
and then for each
answer
block
we're going to get the answer block and
do replace
with
block answer block
clone
note okay unfortunately we can't have uh
we can't just do remove event listener
that will not work so this is a way to
do it and pass through true so now once
again let's just test it out if I just
go ahead and select some
oh two two one
oops
let's do it again
we got
even though we shouldn't really have
blue cheese but if we click on the
others you won't see anything else
popping up
so Austin sandwich modern I feel like
this should have given me a different
sandwich so let's check it out
uh Austin pasta modern let's try that
one
Austin
pasta modern
still giving me blue cheese
hmm
okay so because we are looping even if
we do get the correct answer and then we
do another loop and turns out there
isn't a combination that result's been
going to be overridden by the default
answer we don't want this so I'm going
to put if else else if sorry there's no
results if no result exists only then do
we give the default answer
and finally let's write our disable
questions
question blocks we're going to disable
the whole question block minus the
answer that we have chosen and for this
we need to pass through the question ID
and the chosen answer so let's uncomment
that out and I'm just going to pass
through the question ID and chosen
answer
I'm going to look in the document I'm
going to get element by ID and look for
the question IDs we're looking for the
essential question block so we're going
to look for as we know something with
the question ID
questions and I'm going to save this as
const current
question
block
and now let's get the current question
I'm going to make an array from it array
from
current question block children so all
of its children are going to get all
four things and four each
block
I'm going to say that if
block children
item
one so the second item
in that block so essentially the title
if the titles in a text does not equal
The Chosen answer
then we're going to get the block style
and add opacity
50 to it okay so that is what I have
done essentially what I'm doing is
saying I'm grabbing I'm looking in here
so this is the div with the ID questions
and I'm looking into it I'm getting all
of the children all of the children and
then for each child I'm getting the
child's second item so I'm not getting
the image I'm getting the H3 tag and if
that equals The Chosen answer well then
I know not to disable it so for example
ta-da and you'll see New York is not
disabled same for the sandwich you'll
see all three are disabled and same for
here
wonderful and of course you can't click
on any others great so that is it that
is my BuzzFeed clone I hope you've
enjoyed it
I hope you've learned a lot one last
thing I would do is of course change
everything so it's not RAM and pixels
and of course we need to scroll to the
answer here as well so on the
where do we leave the scroll to answer
so I'm going to use location
href equals and then we're just going to
pick out the answer
active by the ID
answer okay so
that is it and that should scroll to the
div with the ID of answer
wonderful
I just want to clean up a few things so
actually when we set the attribute of
the image link to credit it shouldn't be
credit it should be the image link so
I'm just gonna use answer image for that
and I notice that we aren't getting an
image of Portland
so let's go ahead and change
that Portland is just showing New York
so I'm just gonna switch that out
like so and then let's change everything
so that it's consistent I'm just going
to give the H1 30 pixels let's get rid
of the line height for now
the H2
20 pixels
and the paragraph tag
go let's look at the H2 maybe larger so
50 pixels instead
that's looking
watch
better and just get rid of the line
height maybe let's just make this 15
instead
and finally we just need to add some
cheeses that we are missing in here so
let's go ahead and add a URL for cheddar
a URL for feta
and a URL for halloumi as well okay so
that's all I am doing right
now
and now in the Styles I'm just going to
style the images so I'm going to say
that any image that lives inside the
result block is going to have a width of
100 and then I'm also going to give the
results block a border of solid
and I'm going to use this color
I'm going to say 20 pixels
thick
okay just so the result is like that
great
thanks so much for watching and I hope
to see you again soon
okay so let's do this let's make our
BuzzFeed clone and react
so all I'm gonna do is start a new
project I'm going to go ahead and click
new project on my web store which is the
IDE that I'm choosing to make this
project in if you're using vs code then
please go ahead and spin up your
directory in any way you want I'm just
going to go ahead and select react here
which will essentially spin up the
project that I need with all the files
as well as configuration thanks to npx
create react app and I'm just going to
call this react buzz feed clone and
click create now for those of you who
are not using webstorm please just go
ahead and get up your Terminals and
whatever you choose so for example I can
do this in development I'm going to use
npx create react app so that command to
essentially do what is happening in the
background right now and I would go
ahead and call this react BuzzFeed clone
and just hit enter and that once again
will essentially give me all the files
and all the configuration I need to set
up a react project but I'm not going to
do it this way right I just wanted to
show you I've already got webstorm doing
all of that for me so I'm just going to
let that do its thing and once it's
ready you should be able to see all the
files along with a package.json file
which is going to hold all the
dependencies that we need for this
project
okay
so great and
there we go happy hacking that is now
done I can now minimize this and if we
look in the directory code react was
being clone you will see the punch Json
file which holds all our scripts as well
as all the packages that we have these
other versions that I am using so if
you're watching this future and
something doesn't work it could be down
to the package so just go ahead and
change the package and run npmi making
sure that you are in the directory so
npmi to install
the latest versions of those packages
however I'm not going to do that so
let's put that back to 18 that's an 18
for react Dom
great
now while I'm again just going to clean
some of this stuff up because we don't
need it I'm not going to be writing any
tests or reporting any vitals so I'm
just going to delete these files like so
delete anyway I'm going to delete the
logo as once again we're not going to
need it we're just starting off
completely from scratch so delete that
delete anyway and then delete the test
file because we're not going to be
writing any tests as I said I'm going to
delete the app CSS file as we're going
to hold all our styling just in one file
as this isn't really a very big project
okay so now if you look in the index.js
file you'll see this I'm just going to
get rid of everything that we don't need
so we don't need this import anymore I'm
just going to get rid of the semicolons
just because that is my preference
okay so just like that that is now my
entire
index.js file now my index CSS file once
again is going to start from scratch so
let's delete everything in there and the
app.js well I'm just going to change
this to a functional expression as that
is my preference so const app and let's
use the arrow function here
and we're not going to import these two
things
const app sorry
I have written that completely wrong so
there we go and then we're just going to
return a div for now
okay
so there we go that is now what my
app.js file looks like I've stripped
everything down okay so now if we run
this so let's go ahead and look at the
script npm on start that's what I need
to do so npm
Run start making sure that you're in the
directory and hit enter and this should
bring up my browser with my project on
localhost 3000.
and there we go okay and if I inspect
the page get a back console log we are
now ready to go
wonderful so I'm just going to minimize
this again because that is running let's
get rid of the packaging file get rid of
the index.js file I'm going to keep the
app.js file the first thing I'm going to
do is actually just think of what
components we need to make our BuzzFeed
clone but we're going to have a title
okay that's going to hold you know the
title of the article we're also going to
have a questions block this is going to
hold all four of the questions that we
can answer and then we'll have each
individual question container as well as
a reveal answer block to tell us what we
are what cheese we are
so let's go ahead and do this so let's
make a components directory I'm going to
make a new directory called components
and in here I'm going to create a new
file this is going to be a jsx file and
it's going to be called
questions
block
jsx
I'm also going to create
a question block
jsx or individual for each individual
question and then an answer blocks a new
file answer
block which is going to show up to show
us what cheese we are
and then also the title which is going
to probably be the easiest component so
title jsx
okay great and now let's just create
each component
so there we go let's return a div for
now
and then let's export default the
constant
okay so there we go I'm actually going
to use this I'm going to copy this
for all the others so this can also be
answer
block
and then we export it so there we go our
answer block next we have the question
block individual so question
and then the questions block which is
going to hold all four of our individual
questions and we need to answer in order
to find out what shoes we are
great so that's all our components done
next let's go ahead and import some into
here so I'm definitely going to have the
title import title from
you want to go into the components
directory
and I'm going to get the title just like
so don't forget to put this
and I'm simply just going to use it
like that so now if I just put something
here I am a title and we look at it in
the browser you will see I am title okay
so that has worked just going to make
that a little bit bigger
great
so now that we have all the components
done I think we should start by adding
our data so let's go ahead and do this
I'm just going to serve this up from a
Json file so I'm going to show you how
to do that for your own projects in the
root of your project I want you to go
ahead and create a file which I'm just
going to call database Json which is
going to hold all our data
and now we're going to add all the data
that we need to populate our BuzzFeed
clone so let's do it
well first off in a database I would
imagine that each kind of quiz is going
to be an object in itself and I'm going
to maybe give this the quiz ID right
because if I was working at BuzzFeed I
want each quiz to have an ID and I'm
just going to make one up for now like
we're not actually going to use it I'm
just showing you what I imagine this
would look like a buzzfeed HQ
next we're going to put the title of the
quiz itself we know this is what cheese
are you question and then we're also
going to have a subtitle okay and this
subtitle is going to be this quiz isn't
cheesy or anything
okay
let's put in dot dot
so there we go so that is the quiz
object and each quiz object I imagine
should have
content right and that content is going
to be an array of all the different
questions that we have
so one question block is going to have
the ID of zero let's just say of course
we can give it whatever we want and then
the text of the question block is going
to say kick a vacation destination you
will see how tab 9 is trying to guess
the uh text for me whether it's a I
Thank You tab 9.
so that is what it's going to say and
then we're going to have the actual four
questions that are possible for us to
pick from okay so the first one is going
to have the text
we could have options we could have
questions it really is up to you the
first one is going to be New York so are
we picking New York and then we're going
to have an image
that's going to show us essentially New
York
so I've already picked this out so I
already have an image of New York that
I'm going to use so just like so if you
want to just use your own images what I
would suggest doing is going to do
something like unsplash.com and then you
can literally search for a picture of
New York like this and then click on it
and copy the image address and
essentially that's what we're doing
we're just getting that image addressed
just like so but instead of putting it
in the browser we're putting it in here
okay so there we go and please do
credits whoever's image this is just
because you know we're not paying for it
so it's the least we can do to support
artists uh let's also give it some
alternative text and first off let's
give credit to this photo to Oliver
Nesbitt thank you sorry not neswit
niblet thank you very much Oliver new
bullet for the wonderful photo and the
alternative text I'm going to have is
photo of Empire Building during the
daytime
okay so that's one of our options one of
our questions for the question block
next uh we are going to have text it's
not going to be New York this time it's
going to be Austin and the image of this
is not going to be the images above
we're going to have an actual image of
Boston which I've again picked up
already so you can I will be sharing of
course this project with you so please
feel free just to copy and paste this
whole database if you want to the whole
file I'm just going to talk you uh
through it there so just make sure to
actually understand what it is your
problem
and the alternative text for this is
going to be just a time lapse of
Photography car photography so again
I've just pre-done this to save us time
and credit for this is not going to go
to Oliver this time credit is going to
go to
Carlos Al Gonzo
so thank you Carlos okay so I think you
get the jizz so I'm just going to copy
the other two we're also going to have
Portland as an option
and New Orleans as the fourth option
okay so as you will see each
question block so this is my question
block right here
okay that's my question block and each
question blog's gonna have an ID the
text and then four options to choose
from okay so let's go ahead and create
our next one we're gonna have three
question blocks the next question block
is going to have the ID uh
not titled bridge but nice guess and
description
it's going to be something else too
so this one is going to have the idea of
one and the text is going to be pick
some food because apparently we need to
pick some food in order to find out what
kind of cheese we are and actually we're
not going to have description we're
going to have an array of questions so
this is an array so let's open up our
array and create our first object and
that first object is just going to have
the
text this time of bit set an image of
pizza alternative over any pizza and
credit goes to Adam Hardman for the
project
and change that to give that the integer
of one like so
change this to say text
next we're going to also have a sandwich
so sandwich could be one of the options
you choose thank you it is collective
for this lovely image and the third one
is going to be pasta again thank you so
much for the image we have credited the
author of this photography and then the
fourth it's just going to be a hamburger
with credit to s k
great so now third question block
and this is going to have the ID
of two
the text for this is going to be
pick a
um
[Music]
just like so so previous ones to pick
some food this is going to pick a home
and now we're going to have our four
homes as an array of option for us to
choose from so I've called this
questions but I guess we're asking do
you want a traditional house so here's
the traditional house or representation
of the traditional house with an image
or do you want a modern house so again a
representation of a modern house
or just a
house in the woods
or a house in the
mountains okay
great so there we are there we have our
three question blocks I think we're
finished so let's finish off that array
and next off we're now going to have the
answers that are possible
for us to get so essentially I'm gonna
have answers as an array and each answer
essentially gonna is be a combination
it's going to be a combination of
basically
one
answer from each of the question blocks
but basically every single every single
um
possible option of it so what we have to
do is how many other
that will give us 60 possible
combinations
combination
okay so let's say that the first
and obviously I'm saying that repeat
ones aren't allowed right because you
can only choose one from each question
block that's one combination and if you
get that combination you are blue cheese
okay and the image of this is going to
be some blue cheese that I found
so
just that
and the alt for this is Bluetooth okay
so I'm not going to sit here and make
you just wait until I write out all 60
I'm just gonna paste them in so you
don't have to like so and please go
ahead and just get this from my
uh project at the bottom in the
description so there's lots of very
different cheeses that I have found
manureone
there's a lot okay
great
so that is my database Json file done
now I'm going to serve this up onto the
internet so host it online and I'm going
to do so by writing a script so I'm
actually going to change this start
script I'm going to change this to front
end and I'm going to call this a back
end even though kind of really
I mean whatever you can call a bucket if
you wish and I'm going to use a command
npx Json server to save up the Json
watch and we're going to watch the TV
Json file on Port 8000.
okay so that is how you would write that
okay so save this get a good terminal
stop this from running using command C
or control C and I'm going to have to
install another package which is Jason
server which we wrote in our Command
right here so just go ahead and install
that
and you should see that populate right
here along with all the other
dependencies and there it is I'm just
going to do one more thing and that's on
the database right here what I'm going
to do
in order for us to be able to have an
end point is actually put this all in
another object called quiz
so that our end points can go to
localhost 8000 forward slash quiz okay
and I'm going to take all of this you'll
see everything that we wrote
and then just put it as an object right
here okay so object quiz and this is our
quiz object the quiz ID so save this and
now open up our terminal and I'm going
to use this command to serve up the Json
so this one right here npm run
start back end
and now if we visit localhost forward
slash localhost 8000 so let's go ahead
and visit this one first actually
nothing will happen however when we
visit the endpoint quiz you will see our
quiz is here so I'm just going to make
this a little bit smaller again there we
go there is our Json file essentially
being served up
got it
cool now to populate our app
so
let's go ahead and start up front end
again so making sure you're in the right
directory just to npm run start
front end so this one front end this
time I'm just going to paste it to make
it obvious what we are using and this
will spin up our front end once again so
there we go there's our front end
spinning up once more I'm just going to
inspect this page again and get up our
console log
great
so now I'm just gonna
minimize these and what I want to do is
on the app itself I'm simply going to
fetch the data so for this I'm going to
import
use
state
and use effect from
react which will mean that I can write a
function here so I'm going to call this
fetch data it's a functional expression
which is why I haven't used the function
keyword it's going to be an async
function so stick the word async in
there I'm going to try to fetch
the data from
this URL right here so this one logo
host 8000 forward slash quiz
and we need the await keyword as this
will return a promise and once that has
returned to us I'm going to save it as
the response
okay and once we have the response we're
going to get the Json from it and we're
going to store the Json as Json
okay and once we have all that Json
we're going to set
quiz items
Jason
so const
quiz items
set
use State and we want the quiz items to
start off as null or we could just call
it the quiz right as essentially it's
the quiz we're not working with items
it's it's a quiz so set
quiz let's just make it a little bit
more easier to understand so set quiz so
using set quiz to essentially override
sorry this is going to be false
override the value of false which has
been assigned to a quiz to whatever the
Json is
okay
so that is essentially what I am doing
right here again this needs to be a
weight as this returns back a promise so
once again we're fetching the resource
we're saving it to the response then
we're getting the adjacent from that
response we're awaiting it as it returns
a promise and then we're saving to the
Constitution and whatever comes back we
are saving to the constant quiz right
here which at the start has the value of
false as we've used use state in order
to set the value of quiz to false to
start off with okay
cool let's actually just console log
what this Json looks like just assuming
know what we are working with
and of course we also need to catch any
errors so go ahead and do that and I'm
going to console off any errors that we
have
so there is our function I'm just going
to put it in a use effect so
there we go this is the Syntax for a use
effect and we're just going to run it
without any dependencies so we're going
to call the function in the use of facts
so that you know if it doesn't return
anything the first time it will keep
essentially doing this until we get the
data that we need in order to make our
app work
okay so let's go ahead and see what
we've done I'm just going to refresh
this and
great
so there we go there's our Jason it's
coming back because we've saved it all
under the constant of quiz so there it
is there's what it looks like we expand
it we've got our content which is the
three question blocks and we also have
our answers which are all the possible
combinations of all the answers we got
from our question blocks
great
so this is looking good
so I'm just going to get rid of that for
now and if I console log quiz here
The Flash you will see quiz is false at
the beginning because we assigned it the
value of false and use effect
essentially means it runs until we get
the data back to us
okay wonderful now the first thing I'm
going to do is just feed in the title
and the subtitle into the title
component so let's go ahead and do that
now
so here is my title component and it's
going to feed through the title which I
know is the quiz title and that's if
that exists
and also the subtitle which I know is
the quiz
objects subtitle but only if that exists
as at the beginning you saw this would
be essentially false right is the value
of false so false does not it's not an
object that doesn't have a subtitle uh
property so this won't work which is
what I'm saying a quiz you know exists
So It Isn't false then we want to get
the subtitle property
wonderful so that means that on the
title block we're going to have to pass
you the props I'm going to de-structure
them to get the title and the subtitle
okay just like that and instead of it
saying I am a title here well let's
return a few things actually
I'm going to return a div that has an H1
tag of title and a P tag of subtitle
okay
wonderful
okay so now if we look in here
we go we will see our title and our
subtitle are being fed through from the
quiz object
got it
good
perhaps now it's time to do a little bit
of styling so I'm just going to actually
just minimize this as we don't really
need it get our CSS up
so the first thing I'm actually going to
do is import a font I'm going to do it
from Google fonts okay the font I want
to use is a monster at so if I go to
Google fonts and then essentially what
I'm going to do is just search for the
fonts and the font is called Montserrat
so that's the one that I want I'm just
going to select a few of these okay
let's go ahead and set the thin one
maybe the 300 one 400 500 you can really
pick as many as you wish okay so there
we go I'm going to use the import so I
can import it directly into the CSS file
so just copy this and then just paste it
in like so so that's how you import it
and it means that now we can use the
font family so I'm going to say that I
want to use it on everything so the star
means everything and this is the CSS
rule that I need to apply so I'm just
going to copy that and paste it in here
like so
great I also want to grab the body of
the entire document and I want to Center
everything so for that I'm going to use
display flex and I'm going to justify
content Center so I'm essentially uh
centering everything horizontally at the
moment
next I'm actually also going to let's
make sure let's actually say that this
app
component is returning a div I'm going
to give it the class name of app
okay which means we can now pick out
this class name
and I'm going to say that I want my
whole BuzzFeed app to only be 600 pixels
in width at all times
okay
great
and my H1 element so I want my H1
element I'm only going to use it once so
I'm comfortable just styling the one
each one element if you're using this in
projects then I would suggest you know
maybe picking up the H1 element by an ID
or class name or nesting it and I want
this to be 2.5 Ram
and I'm also going to give it a line
height of 105.
and text align is going to be left and
also for the paragraph I'm not really
going to do much I'm just going to say
that all paragraph elements are going to
have the font size of 1.125 Ram
and a line height of 1.2
so if we look in here now
that is what it looks like okay I'm just
going to get rid of the Google fonts
browser tab for now
cool
now that we have our title let's go
ahead and map out some question blocks
so the questions blocks are the ones
that are going to hold all our four
questions so let's go ahead and import
them I'm going to import questions
block so questions questions so just
like that I'm looking at single quotes
to make everything consistent I'm going
to get that component and this time well
what I'm going to do is say that you
know if the quiz exists
then we want to get its content and map
each content piece
so let's do content
or content item
and I'm going to map it to the question
log element like so
okay so all I'm doing is essentially
looking in here and checking with the
quiz content and checking if the quiz
exists and if it does I'm getting its
content so the three objects I'm going
to map each content item to the question
block I'm going to pass through each
content item let's pass it through as a
quiz item it's a Content item I'm
passing through into the questions block
as a quiz item which means that on the
questions block this will be a quiz item
now and I'm de-structuring it and then
let's go ahead and just console of this
so console log each quiz item so if we
look in here now
I cannot read properties undefined of
map
let's say if quiz exists and
okay
so there we go we are now mapping out
each quiz item and this should
be three okay and there it is
so now with each quiz item
let's actually display it on the
questions block so let's go ahead and do
that by getting the quiz items title
so I'm just going to get rid of that
console log
and let's return a
empty div this time and then an H2
element
which is going to essentially just show
the quiz items
text
so if we look in here
so now we have pick a vacation
destination pick some food and pick a
home we also need to add a key as we are
mapping so let's go ahead and go back to
the app I'm going to get some
parenthesis so that we can also add an
index
so we can add a key to the questions
block so key
index just like so in fact we might be
able to just use the ID of the content
and let's go and see what this looks
like we can go ahead and
foreign
so let's go ahead and perhaps use that
instead which means we don't need this
I'm just going to pass through the
content item ID instead
just like that
great so now we shouldn't have the error
showing up anymore
okay now that we have each question
block let's style it up a little bit so
let's get up our CSS once more and this
time I'm going to add some sine to the
H2 elements
happens
I'm going to say that each H2 element is
going to font size 3.5 or M
a line height of 1.05 and text a line
this time it's going to be
Center
okay
cool and while I'm actually here I'm
going to get the questions container
and while I'm actually here I'm also
going to perhaps give this the class
name
of
question title
okay
and I'm also going to create a div
and give this the class name
of questions multiple containers so that
we can figure out and style it I'm also
going to give this the ID as we are
going to want to scroll to these titles
so let's go ahead and give this an ID
and it's just going to be the quiz items
ID that we passed through
cool so this is looking good now let's
pick out the question title so let's get
up our CSS once more dot question title
as it say class name and all I'm going
to do is just say that each question
title well I'm just going to give it a
width of 600 pixels just like our app
our height a particular height of 210
pixels a background color which I picked
out which is this the purplish color
that I quite
like
let's also give it a border radius to
soften it up a little bit around the
edges and I'm going to say that
everything in it is going to be centered
horizontally so I'm using display Flex
justify content Center but also
vertically so I need to use align items
Center for this and we also need to
assign a height which it already has
okay and I'm going to say that the color
of the text for these question titles is
going to be white so I'm just going to
use the RGB
for white which is
like so
cool
and we also want to grab the questions
container so questions
container class name and I'm again just
going to use display
Flex however this time I'm going to do
Flex wrap as we're going to have four
items in there and I want to wrap over
each other and I also want to use
Justified content space between to make
sure there's equal spacing between each
of the four options
okay and let's also space out a little
bit 16 pixels from the top Zero from the
right hand side 23 pixels from the
bottom and zero from the left side
so there we go
there's each of our titles okay question
titles they look like this and once
again just maybe we're going to zoom out
a little bit so it's better for us to
see what this looks like
cool so that's what we have done now
let's get to putting in our questions
into the questions container
so let's do it
so this time I'm actually going to have
to import the question block the
individual question block into here
question block
individual from our components directory
components we are in the same place
actually so we can just do
this and get the question block and now
for each quiz item so quiz item
DOT questions
I'm going to map each
question to the question block I don't
think we need an index again thanks to
have nine anyway because I think each
question has an ID or at least I'm
pretty sure it does content question
questions
they do not have an ID
because that's one question okay fine so
let's put it back let's put in the index
and I'm just going to underscore as we
don't really need it
okay so into the question block
I am passing through the actual question
which means that here we can destructure
the question
so that we can use it
in the component
so let's go ahead and just return a
button
element for now okay because we're gonna
have to choose each one of the options
so that button for this essentially
makes sense
uh for this let's actually give it the
class name
individual question
lock this time
and then we are also going to in the
button put in an image
element
an H3 element which was a closing
element H3 element is time which is
going to show our question text
and then we're going to put a p element
which is going to have two uh links
essentially the first one is essentially
going to go to wherever we hold our
image so I'm just going to put the
question URL and as the text I'm going
to put the person who took the photo so
the question credit is going to go there
and as the second one I'm going to say
where you can get this image so I'm
going to put href and I'm actually just
going to put a link to unsplash as all
my images are from there so I just want
to credit it properly and in here I'm
just gonna put on Splash
okay
great so if we just look at this now
that's what it looks like each button
has some text which is one of our
options whoever took the photo as well
as where we've got it from and just go
ahead and put a space after the credit
so that it spaced out a little bit and
now let's get the image showing so all
I'm going to do is put the source as the
question
image
like so so once again all we're doing is
getting the all
the image the text and the credit
showing up as well as the alternative
text which I'm just about to use because
as we know each image element should
have some alternative text so I'm going
to get a question Alt
uh question URL doesn't exist we
actually have to use question dot image
in order to get the URL so there we go
so great this is looking kind of cool
let's just go ahead and sell up these
buttons a little bit by getting rid of
the default silent
so let's grab the button by the class
name this time so I'm just going to grab
the class name of question block and all
I'm going to do is say that each
question block has to have a width of 2
8 6 pixels and a height of 286 pixels
I'm going to give it a background color
which is just going to be white
essentially so RGB 255 2x5
255 just like so
a border radius to soften it up of 5
pixels and then let's also give it a box
Shadow one that I have kind of pre-made
already but essentially all it's saying
is that I want it to be black with an
alpha channel of 0.070
uh from the x-axis zero on the y-axis
zero spread within one pixel plus so
it's a really really small box Shadow
and I want the text aligned in the
question block to be in the center
I'm also going to get the margin bottom
to be 15 pixels and any overflow I'm
going to say that
hidden and let's see what that looks
like I'm also going to get rid of the
Border as that is very harsh so Porter
none
so there we
go
okay that is looking quite cool as you
will see overflow is hidden so if the
image is bigger it will be hidden with
the overflowed property
great
I'm also just going to get rid of the
padding as it's causing some funky
Behavior I believe
so padding
zero
just like so so that is looking much
better
now we have our questions block we have
our individual questions this is looking
good however I think we might need to
make these a little bit bigger or maybe
the text smaller as it's hiding
a paragraph element right here
so maybe let's go ahead and do that
in fact let's get our H3 elements
I'm just going to give it margin
10 pixels
okay so that is kind of becoming a
little bit more visible
and maybe the height of these
let's try auto see what that looks like
okay so actually that's not bad
if I want to apply different styling to
these paragraph elements I can actually
gravity question block and say that any
P tag that lives inside of it is
actually going to have a really small
font size let's go ahead and put 11
pixels and I'm also going to make it
italic so I'm going to do font style
italic which would mean that it's just a
little bit smaller and I think that
looks better I'm also going to change
the anchor links so again any anchor
link that lives in the question block is
just going to have a color of uh
this gray let's maybe change it to be
RGB though so
what is that
one five three
RGB one five three one five three one
five three so just like that
great and I'm also going to get rid of
the underline with text decoration none
cool so that's already looking much much
better
uh cool I'm pretty happy with
this
great
so now that we have done that let's
actually get to
picking out the questions and we want to
save each question so let's go ahead and
what should we do first okay let's
we have to scroll to each unanswered
question two and we also have to make
the others disabled ones we put up a
question but let's just do this slowly
let's start from the beginning and let's
actually choose the chosen answers first
so
get rid of the CSS file
get rid of the title get rid of the
answer block
and let's focus on the app.js file so
I'm just going to save this under here
okay I'm going to go and
save this in state so chosen answer
items
set chosen on Sarah items
and use state
it's going to be null as we're starting
off with nothing and we hope to
essentially add stuff into this chosen
answers item which is going to be an
array
okay so that's what that is going to be
let's go ahead and do it
so
what do I want to do well
on the question block I'm actually going
to write a function to handle the click
and if we click a button
so a handle click just like so and what
we're going to do in here is set chosen
answers
items
and then if we want to add to an array
we're going to get the previous state of
the array so this is how you essentially
add to an array and use State and we're
going to get whatever was the previous
state of that array and destructure it
so essentially letting it all spill out
into this new array but we're also going
to add whatever we chose okay so
whatever we chose in here
which is going to be the question text
that we have passed through here as a
prop yeah so what this means if I click
on the button
so on click of the button I want to
handle the click and if I click any one
of these buttons
then the text of that button so New York
or Austin or Portland OR New Orleans
will be saved to My Chosen answer items
on the app but for this to work I
actually need to pass through such
chosen items into here so along with the
question I'm going to pass through set
to chosen answer items I'm gonna have to
pass that through also from the
questions block which is in passed down
into from the app so there's our
questions block so I'm just going to
pass through the set chosen answer items
too
so let's go ahead and actually console
log
chosen answer items get rid of that so
we can see a little bit better let's get
up our console
it's refresh so we can get rid of
everything and if I click on New York we
should save the question text into the
array
Something's Happened
sections and items is not a function at
handle click
question block set chosen answer items
being passed through here we're not
passing that through into the question
block
so let's go ahead and pass that through
as well
okay so that's now being passed down
so it's here we're passing it into the
questions block
and then in the questions block we're
passing through is a plot prop and then
into the question block so we can now
use it and I've destructed it and I'm
using it here got it
and finally instead of having no we're
just going to start off with chosen
answer items being an empty array
instead
cool so now let's test it out and if I
check in here set chosen items is an
empty array and if I click on this we
should pass through the question title
of New York and we do and if I click
Austin New York and also not be there
but if I click any of these we're
essentially adding to that array
also this is looking good however I
don't want to be able to pick any
of these if I click one from this Bunch
right so perhaps let's go ahead and do
that next
so to do this well I need to know what
the chosen answer items are really at
all times or more specifically when I
handle the click right so what I'm going
to do is
pause through the chosen answer items
into the questions block which means
that I need to de-structure it here and
pass it through into the question block
so then I can destructure it in the
question block and use it here so now if
I will add the disabled property to the
button I'm going to say that the button
should be disabled if chosen answer
items
and does not
include
the question text
so at the moment they are all disabled
but if we clicked on one which we're not
able to at the moment then that one
should go in the array and show up as
not disabled so how do we go around this
I'm just going to comment this out for
now
so that's how we would do that however
we also want to keep track of which ID
so which question block ID
so for example this one has the ID of
zero this one has the ID of 1 and so on
we want to know which one has already
been answered so I'm again going to set
this in state up here on the app so
const
set unanswered
question IDs
and a set
const unanswered
question IDs and set an answered
question IDs I'm going to use State and
let's start off with this being an empty
array
and we're going to actually handle this
on the question block again so let's
pass both of these through I'm just
going to pass them through
here so just like we did
with the other state
so we're passing them through into the
questions block which means we need to
destructure them now so on answered
question IDs and set
unanswered questions let's maybe put
this on a
new
line
like so
I think it's set unanswered question IDs
and then let's pass it through into the
question block as well so unanswered
question IDs and set unanswered
questions IDs streams on here we again
are going to get the unanswered
questions IDs and set unanswered
questions IDs and once again I'm just
going to put these on a new
line for us so we can see them all and
welcome
okay
great so on the handle clip when we
click on one of the buttons we set a
chosen answer but we also want to change
the unanswered questions so actually at
the beginning what we should do is set
the unanswered questions well we could
have hard code it to be zero one and two
or we can do it dynamically based on how
many question blocks we have so I'm
going to show you how to do that as it's
more interesting I think rather than
just hard coding it as we know there's
three
so let's get rid of that and under the
fetch data and the use effects I'm going
to write another use effect
to get the unanswered question IDs
so there we go I'm just going to leave
this empty for now and I'm going to say
that if the quiz exists I want to get
its content and map so I'm just
literally going to get the ID of each
object by destructuring it to get the ID
and then just returning
the ID so that's how you would do that
in order to get the ID of each object in
my content array
and I'm going to say this is constant
answer word IDs
just
like so unanswet IDs
okay and once we have those I'm going to
use set unanswered question IDs and pass
through the unanswered question IDs it's
an array so we'll essentially override
this array
okay so great if we console log
unanswered question ideas and have a
look in here
not defined in the questions block
questions
so that's not being passed through
properly set unanswered question IDs
grab that
just make sure that I'm spelling it
correctly at all points
uh typo
unanswered
set and answered
says and answered certain answered
and I believe the last one is here
great
wonderful so now if we look in the
console log
now that we've spelled it right
everywhere
and we need to run this use effect every
time the quiz data changes so just pass
through a quiz as a dependency here
and great so now you will see that the
unanswered question IDs are zero one and
two based off the IDS of these three
question logs
got it
cool
so now whenever we click on a question
in one of these question blocks I want
to remove one of these ideas from this
array
so let's go ahead and do that now
so we are passing that through into the
question block
so what I'm going to do is when we click
on one of the questions
along with choosing the chosen answer
I'm going to use the set unanswered
question IDs and I'm going to filter out
and look for the ID
so the ID does not equal the quiz
item id which is going to be passed down
from the question block so let's go
ahead and call this quiz Item ID
and it's essentially just going to be
well the quiz item is
and get its ID
okay
so should that should be either a zero
or one or a two we're passing that
through as a quiz Item ID into the
question block which means that here we
destructure it and now we can use it
here so get the quiz Item ID
awesome
okay so if quiz exists and if content
exists then we map so just put the
question mark there great so now if I go
ahead and pick New York it should add it
to the chosen answers array and also
this array of unanswered questions the
zero should be removed
are not a function
that's because we need to do unanswered
questions not to set an answer questions
sorry we're getting the array we're
filtering it and then we are passing the
whole new array into set unanswered
questions ID okay so what overriding was
ever in there with this new array
cool
so now let's try again
let's pick New York and great New York's
been added here and zero has been taken
away from our unanswered question IDs
wonderful and if I click New Orleans
New York and New Orleans have been added
but we can't take away zero so it's
still one and two and if I click
Sandwich New Orleans and sandwich has
been added to the answered questions and
two is the only ID left so that's this
one here
great this is looking good now to use
this to disable all the other buttons
right
so we've already written this I'm going
to actually write this
as a const up here const valid pick
and I'm going to say it's a valid pick
if
The Chosen answer items do not include
the question text and
the unanswered questions ID array I'll
put this on a new line
includes
does not
the quiz
Item ID and then I'm just going to pass
through this
and through the disabled
property okay
once again let's see what's happened
cannot read properties undefined or
includes okay so we just need to check
if this exists and check if this exists
great
so now you click on here New York select
an audio this is disabled sandwich is
selected and all three are disabled
traditional is selected or if you're
disabled so we can't click on any of
them and we've answered all the
questions
now to actually gravitate towards the
top most unanswered question so I'm
going to show you how to do that
so this is going to happen on the
questions block as we've given the H2
elements an ID for a reason and that is
because we want to scroll to each one of
them
so what I'm gonna do is
so this is going to happen on the app.js
file however I just want to show you
again that's why we added the ID to each
one of the sh2 elements as we're going
to scroll to them so on the app.js file
I'm just going to get rid of these for
now I'm going to write another use
effect
and this times is going to pass through
an empty dependency for now and I'm
going to say if unanswered question IDs
exist
so perhaps we need to actually make this
null to start off with let's make that
null
if unanswered question IDs exist
and if the unanswered
question IDs length
is suddenly smaller than or equal to
zero we know that all the questions you
know haven't answered but just to double
check and chosen
answer items
land is larger than or equal to one then
we definitely know that you know all the
questions haven't answered then we want
to essentially scroll to the answer
block right so I'm just going to put
scroll
to answer block
however
still if unanswered question IDs exist
in general we just want to scroll to
highest
unanswered question ID
and to do that we need to get the
highest and I can get the highest or
const highest ID by simply getting all
of the unanswered question IDs and
unpacking them into math
Min okay so that will return the
smallest number from this array okay so
that would be the highest ID and now
we're going to grab the highest element
in my document and I'm going to do so by
grabbing the document and using get
element by ID and passing through the
highest ID so that would be either 0 or
1 or a two whichever one is the highest
that exists in that array I'm going to
say this is highest element just like so
and now if highest element
exists I want to scroll
into view
so dot scroll into view
and the behavior of this I want it to be
okay
great
so this is looking good and I want this
use effect to run essentially each time
the unanswered question IDs array
changes okay and also each time the
chosen answer items uh change as well
so let's see if this works so for
example we're scrolling to the first one
however if I answer sandwich here it
will take me back here so the first one
to answer it and then we'll scroll down
to the third one as I haven't answered
it either great and if all three are
answered it should scroll to the answer
block but we are yet to write that code
so let's go ahead and do that now
so the answer block well essentially I
want to actually show the answer block
first and to do that we're going to have
to save this up here
um I'm going to save the state of show
Answer set show answer I'm going to
start off with it being false so use
State false
foreign
have answered everything we want to
scroll to the answer block because we
want to show it right so we're going to
put show Answer true and now we're going
to use this constant social answer in
order to show an element so I'm going to
do so here
and I'm going to say if show Answer
exists then I want to essentially show
the answer
block
just like so and what do I want to pass
through into the answer block well maybe
let's just pass through all the answer
block options and do the logic on there
so I'm going to put answer options and
just pass through
quiz if that exists
dot answers it's okay so that's an array
of all our answers as well as the chosen
answers so our combination so chosen
answer items so now on the answer block
right here
just going to make that a little bit
bigger
I'm going to de-structure the answer
options as well as the chosen answers
okay and we're going to save the results
so const result set
result
use State and the state of it's going to
be null to start so this this is going
to be no let's actually go ahead and
import use state so we can use it import
use State from
react
and now in a use effect
and then just empty dependencies for now
thanks for importing the use effect I'm
going to get the answer options and for
each answer okay so for each object in
my answer options
or 60 of them
I want to say that
if
chosen
answer
s includes
so essentially I'm looking in my array
of chosen answers of the three question
blocks that I have here and it includes
the
answers
combination
first item
or
if the array includes the second item in
our combinations array
or includes the
third item
then I want to set result
with the answer
objects okay
this should be an and and this should be
an and
else
if no results to say for some reason it
didn't work and we didn't get one even
though we should I'm gonna have a
default okay and I'm going to set the
results as whatever the answer options
are
just the first one this is the first
answer object is what we are going to
set as the result
okay
great
so let's see if that works
I'm just going to console log it for now
so console.log
results
and in here
it's going to pick New York Pick Pizza
pick traditional and ta-da we get an
answer object and that is blue cheese so
that is the answer object that we're
getting back let's pick another one
Austin
pasta mountains and this time we get
sanit cologne as the cheese so this is
working we're getting different uh
results each time let's go ahead and
show that
here so I'm going to return
this time a div I'm going to have to
give this the ID so we can scroll to it
and let's give it the ID of
answer
block
and I'm going to give this also the
class name of
answer
lock
and then in here I'm going to the H2
element that's going to say that if the
result exists I want to show its text
and I'm also going to show an image of
the cheese so let's get our image
element and as a source I'm going to say
that if the result exists I'm going to
grab its image and the alt text for this
is going to be the result and it exists
text
cool and now let's style up our answer
block so once again just get up our
style sheet
right here
so dot answer block
and I'm going to say that my answer
block is going to awit of course of 600
pixels I'm just going to hard code it
you don't have to a background color of
this pink that I have preachers and so
RGB 255 61158
and then order radius to soften it out
of 5 pixels display
so we can Center everything align items
Center Flex Direction
column and the font of everything in
here to be white so 245 245 255. I'm
also going to say that the image so the
answer
clock image is going to have a width of
90 percent
so now if we look in here we also need
to actually scroll to this actually so
let's finish out the code that we
started writing here
so this time we're going to go into the
document and get element by ID of
answer
block
and save it as the answer
and then if answer block exists I'm
going to scroll into view and once again
the behavior
is going to be
yes
just make sure that it's consistent
okay great so let's check it out New
York
hamburger modern
I do not scroll why is that
so let's also actually add show answer
to this dependency so that if she'll
answer changes we run this again
Austin Pizza modern and there we go we
scroll to the blue cheese we just go to
the top of this for now however if you
want to offset it further then please
feel free well I'm kind of happy with
this we scroll through and get the title
and then we can move down to see the
full answer
and actually we don't really want a
backup let's just get rid of a backup
for now because null will be the start
state so we don't want that we just want
to override whatever this is so let's go
ahead and say each time the result of
changes that we want to run this is
effect again
okay so now let's try again
okay wonderful so that is working now
and I guess
I mean we can add this back in now if
else
no results
then set result to the answer options
fast
item
so it should be else f
okay
great
because now that null will get
overridden when we get to a new answer
so great we're getting so many cheeses
in some reason the image of Goya did not
work perhaps it's been removed but you
get the gist
okay
now we should really use the and
operator for this instead of the bitwise
operator so that returns a Boolean so
the statement of terms of Boolean rather
than integer so just go ahead and change
that I'm just going to change up a few
more things as well while we're here I
don't think we should be using false
here as technically we should start off
with this state being null instead of
false and then we're going to change
null from being not null to something
okay
so that makes more sense to me and one
last thing I'm going to do is just make
everything consistent in here as we use
RAM and pixels interchangeably so I'm
just going to make everything be REM
okay so please go ahead and do the same
for you will file just to keep
everything kind of a bit neater in here
I don't really like using RAM and pixels
interchangeably so that's essentially
what I am doing I'm just cleaning things
up a little bit I will be sharing this
code in the video description as well so
you can just take this if you need
um of course I would like you to really
practice your skills by you know maybe
applying different styling if you are
using this for your portfolio Okay or
perhaps even a different quiz that is
completely up to you too that could be
quite fun okay
great so nearly done and
wonderful
now one more thing that I want to change
and that is actually back on the app.js
file which really should be an app.js X
part as we have jsx in here I'm actually
going to just use the question mark here
as what we are technically doing is
checking if content exists
and done
wonderful so maybe just change this to a
jsx file that's what I will be uploading
to the code at the end
and finally I'm going to show you how to
not use the document get element by ID
and use the use ref instead however this
is going to be a little bit more
complicated as I'm going to be using the
use or a hook from react but outside of
the component so just go ahead and get
the create ref Hook from react for now
and then just under here let's do it
here I'm going to Define all our
references which are going to be taken
from the unanswered question IDs if they
exist and if they do we're just going to
essentially reduce them
to create a reference for each ID
so this is all I'm going to do I'm going
to show you what this looks like create
graph and call that method and I'm just
going to return
the accumulation
as an object
so if I console log
graphs
and look in here that's what it looks
like at the moment the current rep is
null however we're going to pass it
through into each mapped question block
so I'm going to get the refs now
and on the question block I'm going to
pass you the refs but go into
the ref and just pass through the ID so
we can just use the content ID for this
because that will get us back as zero or
one or a two and now on the questions
block well I need to wrap this in a
forward ref so get the forward ref this
is something again from react so we're
going to have to import that up here
import forward ref
from
react just like so and now we pass
through the ref so our props are here
the ref is the second argument so just
pass that through like that and now we
can just use it here like so and we
don't actually need the ID anymore so
let's get rid of that
great
so that is all I had to do wrap this in
a forward wrap pass through the ref as a
second argument and then use it here
okay so great now how do we scroll at
the moment if we look in here you will
see they all have a current H2 element
so either this one or this one or this
one but to scroll to them we're going to
have to put that in the use effect so
we're gonna have to change up this whole
use effect here
and first off I'm just going to get rid
of this and then I'm going to say that
I'm going to get the rest and we're
going to pass through the highest ID
into that and scroll into View Behavior
smooth okay and we're going to do this
in an if else
right because now if we go and finish
all of the ones that we've clicked
through this will show errors hence I'm
putting in the if else because we're
going to check for the unanswered
questions and chosen answer items first
so just put that in there
like so and in here I'm also going to
essentially have to get rid of this
right so let's get rid of picking out
the answer block by the ID and I'm going
to create a new
reference so I'm going to call this
const answer
graph and use create draft for it again
so just call it like so grab the answer
ref
and on the answer block I'm going to
password a ref which is the answer ref
which means that on the answer block
once again I need to wrap this in a
forward
ref
pass through the ref as a second
argument
and then just use it on here so ref
equals
ref okay and I believe we don't need
this now here
great
so now we are nearly done however I just
need to handle scrolling to the answer
so instead of this I'm actually going to
check if the chosen answer the items
length
is larger than zero as we only really
want to start scrolling once we actually
have some chosen answers right and if
show answer is true well then we get the
answer ref
current
scroll
into view
and then let's also have
Behavior Smith
okay
so I believe this should be it of course
the score is now happening here let's
check it out
what we should also do is add the
missing dependencies from here so I
believe we're now missing the answer
around and the Reps
and we also need to just import
the forward
graph
in yeah as well
now this is causing errors so we just
need to render this once reps exist as
well so just add that to this line on
5th 959 make sure to have current here
too
foreign so now we can go ahead and
select items
it's not letting us scroll to answer
current as well into you why is that
score interview I need to change the
spelling of that
so now we can scroll and it will take us
to a cheese
and we can also start like from the end
and it will take us to the highest
unanswered question and then to the
answer
great
so that's it I hope you found this
useful and I hope you now can enjoy your
BuzzFeed clone in reacts I hope to see
you again soon for another action-packed
walkthrough lesson
okay so let's do it let's go ahead and
create a project I am using webstorm
which means that it will help me get all
the correct files and configuration to
spin up a project fast I'm just going to
hit new project and under here click
react as well as make sure that create
typescript project is checked right here
okay so that is all I am going to do
and then also going to choose to call
this type
script
BuzzFeed clone like so and then just
create okay so that should now spin up
my project for me along with all the
correct files and configuration in this
typescript BuzzFeed clone directory for
those of you who are not using webstorm
please go ahead and use the following
command just go ahead and get a few
Terminals and then wherever you choose
so if I choose to do this in webstorm
projects I would just use npx create
react app my app so whatever you want to
call it and template typescript okay and
hit enter well if I'm not doing it this
way I'm doing it the webstorm way
so once again just go ahead and wait for
that to happen and done happy hacking so
now if I look in here it will give me
all the files and configuration that I
need to start my project including a TS
config Json file
okay so that's what it should look like
just make sure that you have the same
I'm actually going to change this to the
es6 and that should be fine for now the
next thing I do is just delete some
things that we don't need in here so I'm
not going to be doing tests I'm just
going to delete all of these
okay just go ahead and delete
those three
and then I'm going to delete the logo as
well so just delete the logo
delete anyway and then the app tests and
app CSS as we're going to be doing all
our styling in one file
okay we're just going to keep it simple
as this app isn't very big
great so now your index TSX again just
delete everything that you don't need so
I'm just going to delete
all of these lines that are not
necessary to me so that your file looks
like this
I'm so going to get the index CSS and
delete everything from those we can
start from scratch and here as well I'm
just going to delete everything just so
that it turns one div like so and I'm
going to choose this to be a function
expression so const app equals and then
an arrow function right here and then
we're not importing these two so there
we go
great so this is what each of these
three files should look like now
now the next thing I want to do is
create some components so in the source
directory I'm going to create a new
directory called components and in here
I'm going to create a new file this is
going to be for our title which is going
to hold some TSX
so click add I'm just essentially going
to just look like this so let's go ahead
and just copy and paste that in here and
I'm just going to change this to title
and also change this to title just like
so
and then do the same for the question
block
and then next I'm going to create a new
typescript file so type script to jsx
file and this time is going to be to
hold all of my questions so I'm going to
call it a questions block just like so
so it's going to hold all four of my
question options so let's just go ahead
and change this to be questions plural
lock
and questions
blog plural once more okay and just one
more maybe sure to spell that exactly
the same so questions block
so new
typescript file jsx file question block
this time so individual question block
I'm just going to paste that in here
actually let's copy this one and paste
it and we get question block question
block just like so and one more we're
gonna have an answer block which is
going to show us the answer
as to what shoes we are after we answer
all our questions so answer block just
like so paste that and changes to be
answer block and once again
answer
block suggest like that
great
so now that we have those I'm just going
to get rid of these for now
let's get to
adding
some of those components in here so I'm
going to import the title of course from
title
and that's in the components directory
so we go in there and we get the title
okay so there we go we've got our first
component which I'm going to actually
put in here
so title
great and that is the first component
that we're going to feed data into but
first let's actually put our data in the
database so for this I'm just going to
use a free database so you might have
seen me using this before as it is one
that I like to use because it is free
I'm talking about data Stacks so I'm
just going to go ahead and sign in
please sign up if you haven't already
and I'm going to just sign in with
Google
okay so you can choose to do it this way
or you can choose to manually just put
in your email address and set a password
that part is totally up to you
now once in here we're going to create a
new database so just go ahead and click
that and what should we call this
database name what I'm just going to
call it BuzzFeed
and the key space name I'm going to call
this quizzes okay and now we just need
to select a region I am currently in
Europe so I'm just going to go ahead and
put West Europe and click create
database
okay so that will now do its thing
you're going to get shown a token and
please go ahead and get this data I'm
going to show you as I will be deleting
this but this is what yours should look
like so please copy this and keep it
somewhere safe as this is what we're
going to use in order to communicate
with our database okay so I'm just going
to put mine in notes
wonderful so I'm just going to go to
database however this won't be done yet
we need to wait for it to do its magic
and we will know when that's finished as
the status will not be pending anymore
okay so we'll come back to that in a bit
let's carry on here so now I'm going to
go ahead and create a backend for this
project there's just going to be a one
file it's going to be a typescript file
it's not going to be a jsx file okay so
I'm just going to call it server and
that should create a file called server
TS a typescript and essentially all our
backend stuff is going to be done on
server TS and all of our front end is
going to be in the source directory so
that is how I kind of envisioned the
structure for this project
in the savates file this is going to be
responsible for getting our data from
the database and four I'm going to have
to import a few packages so just make
sure you're in the directory and use
npmi to install the packages Express
axios and I think that should be it for
now I also know them on to listen out
for changes to our backend so that you
know we don't run the file once we keep
on listening out to any changes done in
this file so go ahead and install those
three
and great so that is now done
next up I'm going to go to the package
Json and actually write a script to
start the back end so I'm going to add
start back end just like so and I'm
going to change this script to start
front end in order to start off front
end
so my backend script is essentially
going to be no demand to listen out for
constant changes to the server TS file
and that's it okay so we are done on
this right now
wonderful as you will see here here all
the other packages and the versions that
I am using so if something doesn't work
it could be down to the version you are
using of any one of these packages okay
so just make sure that yours are the
same as mine
great
let's have a look at how our database is
doing and the state is now active
wonderful so let's get to adding some
data I'm going to do this using the
document API to help us with this we can
actually use the Swagger UI to make it a
lot more visual so just go ahead and
click on this link right here and that
will load some Swagger documents for us
in order to create our first collection
that's going to install our quiz so
let's go ahead and create an empty
collection in a namespace I'm going to
try it out and all of this has been also
generated for me so that's great and
we're just going to put in the namespace
or key space which we called quizzes
okay and I'm going to create a
collection in here and the name of this
collection is going to be quirky
quizzes okay so imagine we're about
speed and you know they have like a
whole bunch of quizzes and they've
decided to split them out into
collections uh this collection is going
to be called funky quizzes and it's
going to store all our funky quizzes
okay I'm not saying this is the way
BuzzFeed do it I'm just doing it this
way for the sake of tutorial but you can
choose to organize your data however you
wish
so
quirky quizzes is what our collection is
called make sure to actually put this in
double quotes too and let's go ahead and
execute this
and great we get a 201 response that has
worked so that is now the name of our
collection let's grab it
and then we're going to put an ID to
create a new document in here try it out
the name space is called quizzes The
Collection is called quirky quizzes and
we're going to put in our fast Json
object which is going to represent one
quiz I'm going to show you how I'm going
to write this now in fact I'm actually
just going to get a Json document up as
I think will be easier and we can paste
this thing here
so let's go ahead and do that now I'm
just going to get up my project and I'm
actually going to make a new file in
here called sample
data.json okay and just add it like so
now for our sample data well we're going
to have to create an object as this
object is going to represent one quiz
and each quiz is going to have its own
ID so I'm going to give it the quiz ID
and I'm just going to make this up so
let's just go ahead and give it a random
ID and then we're also going to have the
title of the quiz on this occasion it's
going to be what cheese are you question
mark and also we're going to have a
subtitle
if I can only spell subtitles
wow uh and then this is going to say
which
uh and then this is gonna say this quiz
isn't
cheesy or anything like that dot
okay so there's our subtitle next we're
going to have the actual content for the
quiz okay and the content is going to be
made up of an array of three different
questions okay three questions to find
out what cheese we are so there's one
question
and each question is going to have an ID
which is going to have a integer value
it's also going to have some text which
is going to be pick a vacation
destination for the fast
question and then it's going to have the
actual questions associated with that so
there we go the question options are
going to be
New York for the first one so New York
is our fast vacation destination so
let's just put text
New York
and then we're also going to have an
image associated with it that I've taken
from unsplashed so I've actually
pre-made this already so that we don't
have to you know sit here while I search
for images because that would be pretty
boring so here it is this is what it
looks like and we can get it by actually
visiting on splashed searching for New
York and then all I would do is right
click this and copy the image address
okay so that's all I've really done
okay
great
so let's just get rid of that for now
and paste in the original image that I
found so we've got the text we've got
the image I'm also going to have to give
this alternative text as you know we
really should do that uh on images for
the visually impaired photo of Empire
state
building during
daytime
okay so that is just some alternative
text that I have given and we also have
to credit this right as we are taking
this from unsplashed it is essentially
free and they have requested that we
credited so Oliver
niblet get some credit that we're gonna
display
so there is my Essential first
um
question option we're going to have
another one we're actually going to have
four in here that I have pre-made so I'm
just gonna copy them in here to save as
time the next one is going to have
Austin as an option and then we're also
going to have another option which is
Portland so I'm just going to copy this
because I pre-made it and there we go
and then here's our fourth one our
fourth one is going to be New Orleans so
I'm just going to copy that and paste it
in
like so
okay so that is our array of content
essentially let's just check this works
they feel I've messed something up
already
so questions should end here
so that is finishing and then we've got
an object
in an array okay and then that array is
in an object itself so great so there we
have it so questions those are our
questions great
for our first question object which
finishes that and now we're going to of
course have another one so yes we're
going to have an ID this time the ID is
going to be one the title of this is
going to be
pick a
um
and then of course we're also going to
have some questions
okay which is going to be an array
some questions
and then
all right
great
so just like with the first one I'm
going to have
one option for picker home which is a
traditional home then we're going to
have another option which is a modern
home
and then we're going to have a third
option which is a house with some trees
next to it I call just a white house I
guess and then some house in the
mountains so there we go and then we
have one more
question objects which is going to have
an ID to this time a title
of
pick
some food so we are obviously going to
decide what we are by some food in fact
I'm going to swap these out because I
think in the other tutorial that I did a
simplified version of this pick your
food was the second question and then we
finished on picking a home it doesn't
really matter it's just because I want
to keep it consistent with another
tutorial that I did so pick some food
and then the questions for this are
going to be when it's an array
and again we're going to add an object
that's going to represent a pizza choice
because you can choose a pizza and then
another option which is going to
represent a sandwich Choice and then
represent some pasta so let's just wipe
that in and then a last option that's
going to represent a hamburger
okay so great so there we go we have all
of our three
question objects which live in the
content of the question and now we're
going to have the answers
so answer is essentially just going to
be
um objects representing different types
of cheese based on a combination that we
have chosen of the three questions so
there's actually going to be 60 okay
there's going to be 60 answers to cover
all the combinations that we have so our
first object we're going to have a
combination It's a combination which is
going to be made up of an array of let's
say someone picked New York and then
they picked
pizza and then they picked traditional
for the home well if they pick these
three combination if they picked these
three I have said that I want them to be
blue cheese okay great and the image
that they give back is a picture of some
blue cheese that I found again on
unsplashed so I'm just going to whack in
that image like so
okay
great and then we also have some
alternative types of glitches
so that's one answer I'm not going to
make you sit here while I write out all
60 because I'm not sadistic and I'm sure
you have better things to do so I'm just
going to share this file in the video
description okay so you can take it just
copy the contents of this file
so there we go we have paneer we have
Ezra we have Danish blue we have manure
we have so many cheeses
I seem to have used title instead of
text for the two question objects so
let's go ahead and change that and here
so once that is done or you've decided
to just take the file content of my file
I'm going to copy all of it this is
essentially one quiz item right this
object is one quiz and I want you just
to paste it in like so and then I'm
going to ask you to just execute
okay so there we go that is a lot of
data but as you can see that has worked
you get a 201 code and our object now
has a document ID so this is great we
have added that into our database
great
so now we actually need to communicate
with this database so that's what our
server.js file is for it's going to get
rid of the sample data for now
so what was in our server TS file
well we're going to have to import
Express
as well as the request and response type
from it
so from Express
just like
so making sure it's built everything
correctly import Express as well as
request and response from Express and
now I can use Express
and call it to release all of its
wonderfulness and I'm going to save it
as the const
app just like so
and now another thing I'm going to do is
actually uh use app
and then app of course that's Express's
wonderfulness and express comes with
something a method called listen and I'm
going to listen out for changes to my
port so let's go ahead and Define a port
let me do so here cons Port equal
and I'm going to say 8 000. so that's
what I want my server to run on so all
I'm going to do is just say that we're
going to listen up to the port and we're
going to console log
server is running on Port
and then whatever the port
is
great
so now if we get up our terminal we're
actually going to run this script
so
get up our terminal npm Run start back
end
uh it would seem we need to download TS
node as well so just go ahead and
install that package
but also also going to have to install
types Express
and at types
node
which means we don't actually need this
Express package anymore so delete that
and reinstall everything
and under module we're going to just
change this to
common Js
click save
and now just hit npm Run start back end
and great
I think we should we should technically
be getting rid of you know stuff like
this and we will just get rid of that
and Jess as we're not doing any tests or
anything like that I think that should
be it testing Library let's get rid of
those
and I think that should be fine
great so that is now running on our Port
let's carry on I'm just gonna get rid of
this and get rid of this
great
so now we're going to use app get and
we're going to pass through a path or an
end point and let's just go ahead and
call this quiz item to get one quiz item
and this is going to be an async
function in which we're going to have
the request which is a request type and
a response which is a response type
which we have imported from the package
express and what we're going to do is
try
and then we're going to essentially use
axios to get a
resource from the following URL so let's
go ahead and actually import axial so
import axios as well as the axios
response type so axios response type
from
response from axios okay I think we've
already installed axios but I can't be
sure so let's just go ahead and install
again axios I'm just being lazy I could
have actually just looked in here and
there it is
okay so we have axios in here so now we
can use axial sket and the URL that we
need to pass through is essentially the
URL to get all our documents through
such documents in a collection let's try
it out and all I'm going to do is
essentially pass through the name space
so the namespace of the collection is
called quizzes The Collection ID is
called quirky quizzes so quirky
quizzes with an underscore
and we're just going to execute this and
it will return my quirky quizzes Which
at the moment only has one quiz so I'm
just going to get this URL okay I'm
going to get it like so and then
I'm going to just paste it in okay so
that's the URL that I am so I should get
it okay
just disable that hint so you don't
confuse it as code
so great we have the URL it should end
with quirky quizzes and that will get us
all our quizzes
okay and we are gonna pass through
some headers as well so let's put a
comma and make an object and we're gonna
pass through the headers so headers
of
X Cassandra token so essentially
everything we see here x Cassandra token
the header X Cassandra token let's grab
that I'm just going to paste it in like
so
um so let's just make sure to make
everything kind of consistent I'm just
going to give everything single quotes
and our X Cassandra token is going to be
the one that we saved at the beginning
so go ahead and find your token
and just paste it in like so for now
okay so that's one thing we need to pass
through and the second thing we need to
pass through is accept application Jason
so just copy that and put it in
and put this in
single chords as well
so so those are my headers and we are
going to have to await this as this
returns a promise and whatever comes
back I'm going to save as a response
this also has the type of axios
okay so that is a typescript thing
great
now if the response which I know is an
object an object that has a status and
if that status equals 200 well we know
that everything essentially has worked
right
so we're going to get the response and
get the data which is also linked to
that object await it and save this as
quiz
item
okay and we actually can write a type
for this or an interface so let's go
ahead and do that in fact let's maybe
wait a little bit just know that we're
going to actually Define the type of
quiz item and what it's made up of
uh the other thing we actually need to
do is also set a header so set
had a
access
control allow origin and I'm just going
to allow
http
localhost
3000 so essentially our front end again
I'm just going to disable these hints
okay as I don't want you to get confused
and think they are good
and I'm also just going to send
the quiz item
to localhost 8 000 as well
otherwise I'm just going to catch any
errors and console log them out so
console login error
okay we can actually pass that through
the console error
great so let's check this out right I'm
now going to visit
localhost
8000 forward slash quiz
item
and ta-da we are getting the same days
about that we are seeing here we're
getting all of our quirky quizzes
however if I just want to get the first
one okay we only have one in here so I'm
just going to go ahead and get the first
one really
so I'm just gonna do that I'm gonna go
into the data and I'm going to grab the
objects by its document ID so just
like
so but we're going to hard code in here
okay once again I'm just going to put in
single
quotes
so now what we are doing because we knew
the document ID of the quiz item when we
created it okay that was its documented
D what I am doing is in my back end just
looking in my collection of quirky quiz
items and looking in the data of that
and I'm looking in the data to find the
document ID of this and then I'm
returning the whole object so this is
what it looks like now we get the
answers we also get the
quiz ID the subject of the title and the
actual questions themselves too so all
our data is here okay even though
backwards to how we entered it but it's
that
great so now let's move on we don't need
the Swagger UI anymore and we don't need
this either
wonderful so also our server is nearly
done I just want to actually create some
interfaces so that we can essentially
assign types to the quiz item fragments
if that makes sense I'm just going to
create a new file and here it's a new
file I'm going to quote interfaces
dot TS to make sure that it's a
typescript file
and hit enter
okay great and now I'm going to define
the interfaces that make up our quiz
item
so the first interface we're going to
have is the quiz data that makes up our
individual quiz as we know it has a
title which is a string it also has a
subtitle which is also a string and a
quiz ID
as you will see here
there is a quiz ID which is also a
string so let's go ahead and put that as
a string
next up we also have these questions
right so each question block is made up
of an ID and then multiple questions and
then we also have answers which again
can also be made up of a interface right
because they are all kind of the same
and we want to make sure to keep the
same types assigned to each property
so let's go ahead and do that
we're gonna have
content
which is going to be made up of an array
of content and we're also going to have
answers
which is going to be made of the answer
interface
as an array let's maybe go ahead and do
the uh answer interface first so
interface answer just like so
and each of these when it comes with
some text which is a string an image
which is also some string a combination
which is actually an array of strings so
I'm just going to put string as an array
and some alternative text to the image
which is also a string so that's my
answer interface next up we also have a
Content interface so interface content
and let's go ahead and Define our
content well our content let's have a
look here
foreign
object
so let's call this a question perhaps
so literally the content is just going
to have
an ID
and questions and I think it has some
text too it also has some text which is
a string so ID which is actually a
number some text which is a string and
then questions
which I'm going to say as a question
interface I'm going to make that
interface now interface question
let's get rid of these
and the question interface is made of
some text which is a string
image credit and opt they're all strings
so this should be easy
image string
alt string and then the final one is
credit
which is a string
so there we go that's all the interfaces
that we need
let's go ahead and Export them all so
export
quiz data
answer
content and question
making sure that's an export type
great so now in here
I'm actually going to import
the quiz data
from
interfaces
and use it as the response
to this so quiz data
and wonderful so that is our first
custom interface or custom type that we
made
let's move on
it's going to try and minimize this so
you can see the whole file now while we
are here I'm just going to create a DOT
DMV file so create a new file called dot
EnV so you can store all of our
sensitive data so that we don't upload
it onto GitHub and for this I'm going to
have to insert a new package so import a
new package called dot EnV so just go
ahead and import that package and we're
going to actually use it in here so
import
or as dot Envy
from dot e and V
and then dot EnV config
just like so and now that means that I
can actually get this whole token the
sensitive token and store it here so the
token equals
like so and in here I can just use
process dot EnV token like that and now
that will work
we can also do the same for the URL so
let's go ahead and grab this URL I'm
just going to paste it in here
like so by putting in here I'm saying
that you know this is a string it's
implied it's a string and I could just
use process NV dot URL in order to get
that URL
okay so for some reason this is picking
up the URL I can see that here but
I'm still getting errors so what I'm
going to do is just suppress this for
now
and then come back to this later so
suppress with TS ignore okay and save
that and just check this still works
and great
cool so let's move on
so that's our server done we were just
about to create our components so let's
go ahead and
start with the app
again and then pass through the days
that we need for our title but to do
that we're of course going to have to
you guessed it get the data so our
interface is now also done let's remove
that EnV is done our package.json is
done on our TS config is done
let's go write a function to fetch our
data so I'm going to call this fetch
data and it is an async function so I'm
just going to use the async keyword and
in here we're going to try
to get that data so I'm going to use the
fetch API and I'm going to pass through
this URL right here so localhost 8000
and then the endpoint to get my quiz
item and I'm going to await this as it
will return a promise I'm going to save
this to the constant response just like
so and once we have that I'm going to
get the response and get it to Json okay
and again I'm going to await this as
that returns a promise and save the
response as Json so that we can use it
okay and then all I'm going to do is get
that Json and set it up here so I'm also
going to have to import
use State and use effect
from react and I'm going to
save the Json as well let's just call it
quiz
right this is the quiz that's coming
back to us and set quiz and we're going
to start off with the state
being no right now
so just empty and I'm going to say that
these State types we can have are going
to be the quiz data so we're gonna have
to import the quiz data interface quiz
data
or null as we're going to start off with
now so let's go ahead and import that
interface import
quiz data
from
interfaces okay so that we can use it
so I'm now going to do set quiz to set
the cons of quiz
to be whatever the Json is in value okay
so it starts off of being null
and then we use set quiz in order to
change it to be the quiz data
right
and of course we're going to catch any
errors if there are any
I'm going to console
error of the error great once again I'm
just going to disable this hint so it's
not confusing for you
awesome so we've written our function
now I'm going to use use effects in
order to call it
as many times as we need in order to get
that data back I'm just going to pass
through an entry dependency and I'm
going to call fetch data in here and I'm
also going to consult log
the quiz to see if we get that back of
course we need to actually start our
front and two so let's go ahead and do
that in the second tab I'm going to do
npm run
start and then front end as a script we
wrote oops I misspelled it front end and
just hit enter
okay so that should start up our front
end on localhost 3000 I'm just going to
inspect this and see the console log as
I'm hoping our quiz comes back and it
does okay so there's our quiz item uh it
has a title a subtitle quiz ID content
and the answers we're going to pass
through the title and the subtitle into
the title element so let's go ahead and
do that here title and I'm going to pass
through the quiz if it exists title as
well as the subtitle if it exists
subtitle okay
great and let's just close off that
component once more
so what I am going to do now is on the
title I'm going to destructure the title
and these subtitles that we can use it
in here
and the types for each well the title
has to be a string which we can actually
take from quiz data and search for the
title as that interface has the title
property which has a type of string
attached as the value so again I'm just
using stuff I already have so the
interfaces are coming in quite useful
for the button and the front end and of
course we're also going to have a
subtitle as well so we're going into the
quizzes object and finding the subtitle
two so it can be this or it can actually
be undefined as well
okay so just go ahead and do that
because on the first run it will most
likely be undefined as you know we might
not have our quiz uh come through
quickly enough
great so now that we've done that I'm
just going to add an H1 tag that has our
title and a p element that has a
subtitle and close off this div
wonderful so now if we look in here we
get our title and we get our subtitle
this is looking good
so that is not it for our title let's
carry on
next up in the app I'm just going to
actually map out all my quizzes content
onto questions blog so multiple ones
that are going to hold each question we
have like what's your favorite vacation
spot pick a favorite food and so on so
let's go ahead and get that questions
block questions block
so there it is and I'm going to import
it
so import
questions block from questions block
and I did say that for each quiz
content
I'm going to map out
onto the questions
lock
and what I'm going to map out is I'm
just going to put this on a new line
actually
to make it a little bit more readable so
if this exists
we're going to map out let's get rid of
the hinge
each piece of content individual
which has the type of content
okay
we're gonna have to import that
interface from the interfaces
page as well
okay because we did pre-define it so now
we can use it
so that content well I'm going to pass
this through as a quiz item
okay so that it's a bit more readable
maybe as each question block is going to
be made up of the quiz item and I pass
that through as the content
and also going to have to give this an
ID so let's go ahead and just use the
content ID for this so ID
and I can just use the
questions block ID for this as you can
see here
so I'm going to go into content
and get the ID from it
okay
great
so now this I also need to give a key
which I'm going to pass through as the
ID
and as you can see if I hover over it
the content ID is the type of number so
that is good
okay so now we need to pause three of
these things into the questions block
I'm just gonna pick out the quiz item in
fact so let's get up our components and
get the questions block
and I'm just going to pass through the
quiz item
and the type of this
well let's just put this on a new line
the quiz item is going to have a type of
content
so again I'm just using the interface
for this which means it means to import
the content
interface
from
interfaces
the quiz item is now an ID a text that's
a string and the questions which is made
up of the questions interface
and what we're going to return is just
two empty elements so an empty element
sorry and with an H2 element that's
going to hold our
quiz item title and I'm actually going
to also give this an ID as I'm going to
want to pick this out by the ID later so
that we can scroll to it and this is
going to be the quiz items ID
right as the content or the interface
right here does have an ID we can use
which is a number however we can't
assign a number to an ID so I'm going to
have to turn this into a string so that
the ID attribute can use it
great
and at the same property title does not
exist on content why is that
let's have a look in here
that's because it's text
so that's a great little helper for us
we're going to use text so we've got the
H2 element
and great we get all three texts of each
of the content objects so pick a
vacation destination pick some food and
pick a home let's carry on next under
each one of these I actually want to
show four of the options that we added
okay so each of the four questions
associated with each object so let's do
that next
to do this I'm actually going to map
that out onto a question block so let's
go ahead and import
question
lock
from question block so we're in the same
location as it and I am going to
essentially map this out I'm actually
going to create a div faster and that
div is going to have the class name
of
questions container
and then for each quiz item
questions so if quiz item exists
and for each of the questions I'm going
to map each question
which has the type of requestion
interface
which we're going to actually
import
from the interfaces so the question
interface let's have a look at it one
more time here is the question interface
as text image or on credits or as
strings
and we're going to map that onto the
question
block
element
okay
great
I'm also going to have an ID which is
the type of number
or maybe let's just put the index like
so I'm going to comment that like that
because we're not really going to use it
so this means that we need to give this
a key which is going to be the index
that I am not using I'm also just going
to pass through the whole question right
onto the question block
let's get rid of this
also make sure not to use curly braces
here
great
so now on the question block
I'm going to de-structure the question
which has the type of question which I'm
actually going to move this as I know
we're going to have a few more props to
pass through here so I'm just going to
do it like so and I'm going to say that
question as a type of question
foreign
otherwise interface which we're going to
have to import so import question
interface from the interfaces
file
and this time on the question I'm
actually going to return a button right
as we want to click on each one of the
buttons
and in fact let's actually give it an
opening and a closing tag as we're going
to want to put other stuff in this
button so button
right and in the first
tag I'm just going to pass through the
class name
because I'm going to want to style it up
I'm going to give it the class name of
question block
and then on click of this well I'm going
to want to handle the clicks I'm just
going to write a function called handle
click
which we're going to Define up here
again also in the button what I'm going
to want to add a few things right I'm
actually going to put in an image which
is going to have the source of the
question that we're passing through
image and the alternative text that
comes with it which comes with a
question object is Alt
and then we're going to have an H3
element which is just going to have the
question text
as well as a p element which is going to
have two anchor tags so just like so one
two the first one is going to take us to
the URL of the image which is actually
also stored in the object as image and
as the text I'm just gonna actually put
whoever took this so I'm going to get
the credit that is associated with the
question object
okay so if we look in here question
credits actually I think it's credit
though is it credits or credit what does
it say in our sample data it's credit so
just change that to be credit just like
that
great and that will get rid of those
cardio lines
and in the next one the href I'm
actually just going to put https
for www dot
unsplash
foreign
[Music]
okay
and then a space here
just so the two whites aren't so close
together
great
out
I'm just going to rerun this as doesn't
seem to be registering my change in the
interfaces
and great okay so I'm just going to
inspect this once again so we can get up
our console log but essentially we've
done it okay we have got a question
object pick a vacation and it shows us
four options as well as you know who
took it and where to find the image and
then pick some food and then pick a home
so now before we do anything else let's
take a break and do some styling okay
let's do it
so let's get up our index CSS file
right here
and perhaps let's just minimize all of
this
for now
great
so first off I'm just going to go to
Google fonts as I want to import a font
called Montserrat so just go ahead and
go here and then all I'm going to do is
simply search for the font
called Montserrat so this is it I'm just
going to select a few line weights so
you can do the thin one you can do the
300 one the 400 the 500 it's up to you
and then what I'm going to do is import
it with this option so I can import it
into the CSS file so go ahead and copy
all of that and just whack it in like so
and this just means that now I can use
the font family so I'm going to say that
everything star means everything is
going to have the following font family
and that is font family Monster Rat so
I'm just going to copy this let's get
rid of that for now and I'm just going
to paste it in like so
and that's it now I'm going to Center
everything horizontally and to do this
I'm going to use display
Flex
justify content Center to Center
everything horizontally
now I'm going to actually give my app
the class name of
app okay so that I can pick it up a DOT
for class name and all I'm going to do
is just give it a width of 600 pixels
next up I am also actually going to
say that I want every single H1 element
that I have used to have the font size
of 2.5 RM
and a line height of
1.05 and text aligned to be
left
okay so that's all my H1 elements and
all my H2 elements that I use in this
app are going to have the font size so
this is standardizing all of these fonts
3.5 Ram
a line height of again 1.05 and text a
line this time the center
okay
and any H3 element that I use is just
going to have a margin of 10 pixels I'm
going to keep the default sizing
any P element is going to have the font
size of 1.125 Ram this time and a line
height
line height
of 1.2
okay
great
so there we go we've just changed up a
little bit for now
wonderful next let's style up the title
blocks so this is going to be on the
questions block
I'm going to give this specific H2
element the class name of
title
block
be sure to spell that the right way and
this time I'm going to pick out the
title
block
just like so and all I'm going to do is
make sure that it has a width of 600
pixels
I'm going to hard code a height of 210
pixels so they're all consistent and
give it a purple color as the background
color so RGB is one I picked out earlier
69 221
okay great and let's round it off so I'm
going to give it a border radius of 5
pixels and I'm also going to Center
everything so display Flex
justify content Center to Center
everything horizontally on this occasion
and I'm gonna align it vertically two by
using align content Center or align item
sorry I should say and we've given it a
height so we'll Center it to this height
and I also want the font to be white so
I'm just going to pass through the rgb4
right
next I'm also going to grab the
questions container that contains all
the questions okay all four of my
questions for each question block and
I'm going to use display flags and then
I'm going to make them wrap over each
other so Flex wrap wrap so they're not
stacked and I'm going to also justify
the content between them space between
so that they just look a little bit
better okay
uh and we also have to actually use this
class name on the questions container so
in the questions block
okay this should say questions container
as that's what we call the here
questions container and now let's also
style each of the question blocks so
let's grab this button that has the
class of question block I'm just going
to remove any default styling from it
really I'm going to do border none let's
see what this looks like
okay so that's what it looks like at the
moment
it is a little bit big so let's make
them a little bit smaller I'm going to
hard code their width as 286 pixels and
our height as 286 pixels too so they're
like little squares and great you will
see they are wrapping over each other
the images are kind of going over so I'm
also going to do overflow hidden
overflow hidden and that will stop the
images from
leaving these squares
wonderful so this is looking so much
better let's continue doing some styling
we're losing some of the text here so
what I'm also going to do actually let's
get rid of the Heights I'm just going to
get rid of that so that it just kind of
lets it do its thing I'm also going to
make the text smaller however let's
finish off signing this question block
first I'm going to actually give it the
background color of white
okay and instead I'm going to give it a
box Shadow and also border radius so
everything's going to be that little bit
softer and box
Shadow is going to be RGB a and I'm just
going to make it black but then with
0.07 Alpha
and I'm going to say I want 0 x axis
Shadow 0 Y axis zero spread and one
pixel blur so it's a very very light
Shadow I also want all the text to be
centered so it takes the line Center and
let's just give it some more margin at
the bottom 15 pixels margin on the
bottom okay so now it looks a little bit
more like this I it did say I want to
make this text smaller but only the
paragraph text inside the question block
so any P elements inside the question
block we're going to override the
default key sizing
I want to give it a font size
of what did we make this one
let's make it 0.5 RM I think that should
be okay and font
Style metallic
okay maybe that's a bit small but I mean
you can change it too whatever really
you wish great and then maybe let's also
give each of the a tags that live inside
the question block text decoration
none to get rid of that underlined uh
color
style as well as I'm going to give them
a
grayish color so color RGB three one six
three one six three one six
okay
maybe a little bit
darker
okay I mean it's really up to you I
don't think that's very readable so
maybe let's get it
wonderful
so there we go and then let's also get
rid of the padding on these so I'm gonna
get rid of the padding on the question
block padding zero
great so now that we have that I think
we're now ready to do the handle click
for handling the clicks on all of these
buttons what I really want to do is uh
collect all the chosen answers and if it
shows an answer is I guess attached to
one of these question ideas so at the
moment this one this whole block
right here
hold on
let's try
make these a little bit smaller
so this
questions object has the ID 0 this one
has the od1 and this one has the id2
let's also collect them so we can figure
out which ones have been answered and we
can also scroll to each of the topic so
the highest ID that hasn't been answered
so all of these things we're going to do
there so I'm just going to get rid of
that for now
so let's handle that on click well cons
handle click what do we want to do
like I said we want to start collecting
all the chosen answers so we're going to
do that up here so I'm just going to do
const chosen
answer
items
and set
chosen onto items
I'm going to use state to say that this
is an empty array to start with
okay
it's an empty array
and this is going to take the types of
string as an array as it's going to be
an array of strings let's make this
small
and now we're going to use set chosen
answers to override this empty array or
in other words actually we're going to
take that array and put stuff into it
I'm going to show you how to do that in
use state so this is going to happen on
the question block which means we need
to pass through that method all the way
into here I'm going to do that here so
handle click I'm going to set chosen
answer items and we're going to get the
previous
state
of the array
and then we're going to destruction
whatever's in there I'm going to put in
the new item and on this occasion I just
want to put through the question text so
whether it's uh New York or Austin or
Portland OR New Orleans that's what I
want to put in my array so that is how I
would do it well of course we need to
pass this through from the app so it
exists here so we're going to have to
pass it through into the questions block
just like so so I'm passing it through
into here and then here I'm going to
have to destructure it so let's just
pass it through like so
and
this is going to be
a function
which I'm then going to pass through
into the question block of course
so there we go and on the question block
once again destruction the prop
so just pass it through and this of
course is a function so now I can use
that here of course we need to actually
uh assign a type to this well this is
going to be an array
of strings
so string array
cool so now back in here if we console
log
The Chosen answer items
where is this on the questions block I
clearly missed
an s
let's get our consort log out
so at the moment I'll raise empty but if
I click on New York it will put the
string of New York in there if I put New
Orleans it'll be New York and New
Orleans and then New York New Orleans
sandwich and so on however we don't want
this to happen really right if we click
on one of these we want to disable all
the others so that we can't put them in
our array and to do this we're also
going to have to collect the unanswered
question ID so by questioning me this
whole question object IDs this is zero
this is one and this is two so to do
this well once again on the app I'm
gonna const
uh what should we call this this time
let's go ahead and call it unanswered
question ideas on on swords
question IDs
set unanswered question IDs use State
and the state of this to start off with
um it's just going to be
an empty array
and this array is going to take numbers
so an array of numbers
just like so so once again I'm going to
pass this through
into the questions block
so which means I need to de-structure it
here
and again this is a function so function
and I'm just going to pass it through
into the question block two
which is on the question block once
again I'm passing it through destruction
of the prop and this is a function type
great
so on the handle click well we should
actually in here first of all
um we could go ahead and just say that
to start off we have these three IDs as
we have you know three question IDs or
we can do it dynamically based on
exactly how many questions we have I'm
going to show you how to do that as I do
think it's more interesting so to do
this I'm just going to do it in a
separate use effect so let's go ahead
and do that here use effect
and I'm just going to on um
okay so we're going to get the quiz and
if it exists we're going to get its
content and if that exists we're going
to map and get each item of the content
and destructure its ID so I'm going to
go to the object and get its ID and then
I'm just going to return the ID okay so
that's all I am doing and I'm going to
save this
put some parenthesis around this
and yes this is a number
however the whole object that the ID is
in is technically the content so we can
do this
and then let's save this as an answered
IDs Okay so we've saved our const
and I'm just going to use set unanswered
questions to be the unanswered questions
ID so I'm going to pass that through in
order to set this constant
okay
it seems like this could be undefined as
it might not exist so I'm just going to
add number
or undefined as a type here
okay
okay so just you can read that that's
what it is
so now we should have
uh let's console log it out of our
unanswered questions
or unanswered question ideas sorry
let's have a look I'm just going to get
rid of any other content actually let's
keep that there so I'm going to keep
that console log
now if we look in here
we don't want this to run forever in
fact I only really want to run this use
effect if the quiz changes so quiz
stop this running loads of times okay so
great so now if I click on New York
you'll see New York coming here
and here is our dynamically produced
array of all our unanswered questions so
now if we click on this I want to change
this array so it gets rid of ID 0 as
this belongs to the question group of
id0 so let's do it
so this is going to have an on the
question block I'm going to set
unanswered questions and what I'm going
to do is override the array that's in
there and like to do this I'm going to
get the unanswered question IDs and
filter this actually means that we need
to pass this through as well as these
set and answered questions so let's go
ahead and do that let's start from here
I'm going to pass through the unanswered
question IDs
which means that on the questions block
I need to pass through the unanswered
question IDs and then pass it through as
a prop of course as well let's maybe do
it in the same order
and this is going to be array of strings
you can also just do
which is numbers it's number
yeah array of numbers
or
undefined
and now on the question block we of
course also need to pass it through and
it's an array of numbers
or undefined
which means we can now use it here so
we're using it here
to filter
and if it exists you're going to filter
each ID
and return only if the ID does not equal
the quiz
item id we are answer quiz item id which
we're again going to have to pass
through this time from the questions
block so the question blocked when I
pass through the quiz item id which is
actually the quiz Item ID right because
it belongs to
the quiz item itself or the content okay
so this will either be a zero a one or a
two right I hope that makes sense
okay if it doesn't let's have a look at
the interface so let's look in here
I'm essentially getting this right the
content and that's what I'm passing
through into the question log
great
so we also need to pass this through as
a prop which we forgot to
okay okay
so I hope that makes sense I'm also
going to give this the type of number
well I'm here and
great
so now when I click it it should get rid
of the quiz item id let's have a look
seems to be wrong here IDs that should
be on
the app
IDs
and we also need to pass the quiz item
id onto the question block
so let's pass that through as the first
one
and this is going to be a
great
so now if I click New York
New York will be added to My Chosen
questions array and my unanswered
question IDs zero will have disappeared
as this belongs to the group with the ID
of zero and if I click on here well
either 2 will disappear and it does okay
and traditional husband added great and
if I click on here we have answered all
the questions so there is nothing in our
array so now I'm going to use this in
order to write a const
called valid pick
and if I look in my chosen answer items
array and of course it exists and it
does not include the question text so
bank will not include so if it does not
include that and
we look in the unanswered question IDs
array and if it exists and check if it
does not include
so not include the quiz item ID so if
these two things are true then we know
we've got a valid pick
which means we disable all the other
buttons so now I'm just going to pass
through this
from the app as well as it's another one
we need to pass through so on here I'm
just going to pass through
chosen answer items into the questions
block
so there we go chosen answer items
I'm going to pass that through here as
well and this is
an array of strings
and then I'm also going to pass it
through here
which means that in here
as well not again this is a
array of strings
great
so now if I click New York all the other
ones should be disabled so I can't pick
them sandwich
and traditional so great so now that we
have done that let's get to scrolling to
the highest uh question group so I'm
going to do that right here and we're
going to use a use effect for this
so under the last use of fact I'm going
to use use effect again
okay so just get up
this following
syntax
and we're going to scroll to the highest
unanswered question ID so to do that I'm
going to actually get the unanswered
question IDs and I'm going to
destructure them into a method called
math Min which will literally return the
smallest number from anything that's in
here and I'm going to save this as the
highest ID
okay
so that's all I have done that was
actually super easy I'm also going to
run this use effect every time the
unanswered question IDs change
and now I'm going to look into my
document and get anything with the ID of
the highest ID
okay and I'm going to save this as the
highest element because we're going to
want to scroll to it okay so I'm going
to grab the highest element
making sure that this is in parenthesis
say that a little bit bigger for you
now I wouldn't usually recommend using
the document get element by ID in a
react project but as this is kind of
hard to do with the use refwork I've
shown you this way but if you're
interested in how I would do this using
the use ref hook then please stick
around to the end and I'll switch this
out okay I'll switch it out so you can
see
and making sure this is a string as at
the moment is a integer and get element
by ID won't take that so now we're going
to get the highest element and I'm going
to use if it exists actually I'm going
to do scroll
into view and I'm going to put the
behavior as smooth so Behavior
smooth
okay and disable this
great
so we actually only want to do this if
unanswered questions IDs exist right so
I'm going to grab this
and check for it before we do any of the
following Behavior
okay so there we go
so now
I go ahead and fix them from here it
will scroll to the top one and if I pick
something from the last one it will
again scroll to the top one until we
answer it okay so that is pretty cool we
have now finished the scrolling Behavior
now if
unanswered questions length
is smaller than or equal to zero
and just to You Know cover ourselves
chosen answer items length
is larger than
or equal to one
well then we want to find the answer
block which we're going to have to make
so let's go ahead and create our answer
block I'm going to give this to the
class name of answer block just like
so oops
and we want to scroll to it so I'm going
to essentially
once again look in our
document and get element by ID
of answer
lock it's gonna disable this hint
and I'm going to save this as the answer
block
and if the answer block exists
I'm going to scroll into view and once
again I have the behavior as smooth okay
so we also want this to run anytime the
answer items or the chosen answer items
change
great
so that's really it next up let's get to
actually displaying our answers so we
are actually going to want to show the
answer block so let's gonna go ahead and
import it import
answer
block
from answer block and I only want to
show it so I'm actually going to set
this as const shell on
tour
set
show answer you state Boolean and I'm
going to start off with it being false
and I'm going to use set show answer
to
actually
true
when we want to
show the block so the answer block so if
show answer is true then we want to
show the answer log component so that is
how we would write that
okay so expect that we need to do our
outside here so just like that
now what do we want to pass through into
the answer block but we want to pass
through the answer options that we have
so he's going to pass through all of
them I want to do the logic on the
answer block and we're also going to
pass through our chosen answer items
okay I'm just going to pass in through
as chosen answers
but we have them saved here as chosen
answer items
great
our answer options are actually going to
be your quizzes and if our quiz exists
answers
okay so everything that comes with the
database
so now on the answer block
we're going to have to pass through
the answer
options but also the chosen
of course just like that and the types
of these are
well I'm just going to put this on a
new line for us I will format this a lot
better A little bit later
when I upload these files at the moment
I'm kind of rushing the answer option is
going to be well it's going to be an
Erasure but it's going to also have the
interface of answer that we pre-written
so an array of the interface answer or
is going to be undefined
we of course need to import the answer
interface so answer
interface
from
let's go back on more interfaces
and the chosen answers is going to be an
array of strings so let's just go ahead
and undo that
now in here what do I want to do well I
essentially want to show an answer but
to do this I'm going to have to
essentially check
to all our answer options that we have
got from the database to see if it
matches the combination that we have for
the chosen answers so what I am going to
do let's just return an empty dependency
is get our answer options so essentially
the ones from
the database and for each
answer
which is going to have the interface of
foreign
just go ahead and put this in some
parenthesis
I'm going to have to say that if
The Chosen answers array that we have
you know done on our client
includes
answer combination
the fast in the array and
includes
the second item in the array from our
database
and the third item
well then I want to set the results
as the answer
right
which means we also need to actually
import use effects as well as use State
into here so we can use both and I'm
going to use const
results
set result
use state
and it's either going to be the answer
or
no
and essentially I want to do this every
single time the chosen answers change
okay so now there's a console log or
result
so now if I go ahead and pick New York a
sandwich and mountains I get as Darrow
as the cheese and if I pick Austin Pizza
and traditional Eggert palmito so this
is looking good the final thing I'm
going to do is actually just show that
result in here so all I'm going to do is
actually scroll to this so I'm going to
have to give this the ID because we
haven't actually given this an idea yet
or answer
block so that we have something to
scroll to
and I'm just going to use the H2 element
to say that if result exists I want to
just pass you the text of the result and
then also the image so I'm going to use
the image element and the source of this
is going to be the result if it exists
image as well as the alternative text
which is going to be the results
objects if it exists
text great and now some final styling
so let's get up our CSS files
and I'm going to grab my answer
block
I'm going to give it a width of 600
pixels a background color of pink that
I've picked out previously so this is
just a funky one that I have found
I'm of course going to soften up with a
border radius because they are my
favorite and I'm also going to do
display
Flex
align items Center to Center everything
vertically Flex direction is going to be
column
and color for the text is just going to
be white so there is the RGB for white
and I'm also going to say that any image
that is inside the answer block is just
going to have a width of 90.
great so
let's try it out I'm going to start from
the last one modern and should take me
up to here I just miss it there and pick
pasta and then pick Austin
we get cheddar cheese okay so that is
cool however something funky did happen
it didn't all um I had to click Austin
twice so it must be something on the use
effect
let's go ahead and give this index a
number type while we're here
foreign
show Answer changes
let's try this again New York sandwich
modern and we get roomy the image is
broken but that's because we took it
from Wikipedia so maybe someone took it
down let's try another one New York
Pizza traditional and blue cheese okay
so this is looking good and of course we
can you know start from the bottom house
pasta New York
and we get bread cheese again this is
taken from Wikipedia so the image is
broken but you get the gist now before
we run off I just want to clean a few
things up I'm gonna get rid of this I've
left it to last as this is a bit
Advanced so if you're happy with it just
leave it just know it's probably not the
best practice and that we should use use
ref so I'm just going to get rid of that
and all I am going to do is import
create ref from react
just like so and under here so perhaps
just get rid of this console log as well
so before we fetch the data I'm going to
Define our refs because we're going to
be picking out a ref outside of the
components to scroll to so what I'm
going to do is get the unanswered
questions
so unanswered question ideas and if they
exist I'm going to reduce
them so I'm going to use accountant ID
that sounds good to me and then I'm just
going to look into the objects by the ID
and then for each one I'm going to
create a reference
okay so that is what I am doing we're of
course going to have to add some types
to this I'm just going to console log
refs so we can see what is going on
so for this I'm going to actually make a
reduced type
to reduce
type
up here and let's refine it to type
reduce type
and then I'm just going to add the ID if
it exists
which is going to have an object okay so
that's all I have done and then
here
you need to say that this ref that we
are making art is an HTML
give elements
or let's just put them now
okay
just make sure that says type
great
so this is looking good we'll put as
unknown
as key of the reduced type
as well just so we can identify that
and we're going to create objects out of
all of that great
so what's it not liking here now
let's maybe just put any
as well okay so we shouldn't really use
any but you know I'm at the end now I'm
just showing you this alternative better
option of how to use ref instead of
using document get element by ID
and now let's just return the
accumulation
so now if we look in here
this is what is the return we've used
the unanswered question ID so here to
create this object that has the create
ref in it so it's an object of objects
okay and we're going to collect them all
in here and to do that I'm just going to
scroll down to the questions block pass
the ref through get the Reps and then
pass through the content ID so in fact
can we just do ID I think we can
they should probably be content ID
you should probably get rid of this
actually and just make this the content
ID instead
and then we can just use the content ID
here too
great
so now on the questions blog so let's
find the questions block we need to pass
that through as a reference so here are
all our props and the reference is the
second argument I'm going to wrap this
in a forward ref just like so and then
import that from reacts so forward
breath
and great and it means we can now get
rid of this ID as we don't need it
anymore and I'm just going to use the
ref instead okay
great and then we can just infer
parameters from usage if we want
there we go
great
so now if we look in here
you will see that has been populated
with the H2 elements okay just like so
so now let's go ahead and use that in
order to scroll to the highest element
so I'm going to have to rewrite the use
effect for that so this one right here
so once we get the highest ID we're
going to use the refs we're going to go
into them and pass through the highest
ID we're going to get the current
scroll into View Behavior smooth
okay great and just disable this hint
wonderful and of course we also need to
scroll to the answer block so I'm going
to do that in its own
if statement to show Answer exists
then we're going to scroll okay and I'm
also going to pass through
a check to see if the chosen
answer items length
is larger than zero because we don't
want any scoring to happen when we first
load our page so that should get rid of
that okay and just keep the unanswered
questions check
great so now let's create another
reference let's get rid of that I'm
going to call this answer ref
I'm going to use create ref for it and
just call the method and then I'm going
to use the answer ref
pass it through as a reference into here
let's also check that refs exists
you know
before reading it down here now on the
answers block let's just put this on a
new line
just like so I'm also going to pass
through the ref but this time is the
answer breath okay so that means that on
the answer block we again need to pass
it down as a second argument so outside
of the props and then wrap this in a
forward
ref
just like so which we're going to have
to import from react to import forward
graph
foreign
use current
scroll into view and then just put the
behavior as smooth
okay
great
so this is looking good I'm going to put
this as an else
because this works as an elf else a
little bit better now
let's also add the missing dependencies
so answer ref
current
and refs
and we need to assign a type to this
well once again I'm just going to get
that from here it's going to be an
htmlive element or null
okay
great
so now in here let's also check if
answer ref exists
so and answer ref
all right
and
great
maybe let's add that to be current as
well
okay
wonderful I believe that is it let's
also add the type here so
I'm just going to copy this right here
and paste it
it doesn't it seem to like that so let's
go ahead and just put any as well
great
let's go back in here
let's run it if the children items
length
changes
and of course we cannot get rid of this
and just pass through the ref onto the
wrapping div so now let's check it out
let's go click here
click here and click here and we scroll
to the answer
wonderful now one last thing I'm going
to do and that is in the index CSS file
I want everything to be consistent so
I'm going to change everything to have
REM instead of pixels because at the
moment I'm kind of using both and I
don't really like that
so let's change this to be 37.5 REM this
to be
0.625
um
this to be 37.5 gram
and then we've got
13.125 gram
a border radius of
0.313 Ram
a width of
17.875 gram
again a broader radius of
0.313 RAM
a margin bottom of 0.938
um
it's got one pixel here so let's change
that to
this
let's change the answer block to 37.5
gram with a border radius of
0.313 RAM
and there we go
Okay so we've done it we have
essentially finished our BuzzFeed clone
in typescript I'm going to share this
with you I'm going to clean it up so you
know everything's indented a little bit
better and we get rid of the console
logs so if you want to check out my code
then please go ahead and do that let me
know what you think in the video
description and I will hopefully see you
again soon
thanks very much